inaudible
good morning everybody and welcome to
the plans committee of the 12th of may
welcome to and you may be viewing this
meeting on george's youtube
uh we're not expecting any fire drill
this morning so if the alarm goes off
the layout
is the way you came in please don't use
it
and
unless the committee in office is
to introduce themselves and if he could
speak up please i'm not sure how
sensitive that is
and i'll start i'll start with myself
i'm councillor chris leather and i
represent norah
castle pete watson i represent brody
council roosevelt and i represent two
rivers and three walls
good morning my name
ruth is and i represented east
hello richard wiseman i represent the
cheviot langtry ward
good morning i'm richard mountain i
represent heart reward
good morning my name is dale mcgoff and
i represent liverpool
thank you
that's the committee and i'll start on
the on my left with
with the planning manager uh good
morning members members of the public my
name is shaun harrington and i'm the
planning manager council
good morning my name is stacey dory and
i'm the head of legal governance for
charles district council
good morning my name is uh christine i'm
the lead planning officer
good morning
[Music]
john williams public health and housing
manager
good morning democratic services
thank you everybody
um
right we move on then
one on the agenda is apologies for
absence
no apologies we've got a full house
again
item two on the agenda are the minutes
of the last meeting
on the 14th of april pages five to 16 on
on your agenda and i'll move those from
the chair i'll second councilor lock
second
could you take the vote on those minutes
please stand up
thank you chair councillor
councillor brown
councillor christy
councillor craigie
[Music]
thank you that's eight four in one
abstention chad
nobody else has and there's no other
views in the entire minutes i'm just
intrigued why councillor leather's views
are there but nobody else
yeah
um
those bullet points there i think they
raised not just banknote
i think several other committee members
mentioned them
that's how they've been recorded so
i'm just ready
i'll make sure councilman christie you
get mentioned
okay we'll move on item 3 is
declarations of interest members with
interested in should refer to the agenda
item
and describe the nature of their
interest when the item is being
considered
elected members of devon county council
and town parish councils
who've considered a planning application
by virtue of their membership of that
council called a personal interest
and are deemed to have considered the
application separately
and they express views of that council
do not find the members concerned who
consider the application of fresh
because it's only at this meeting that
we have all the full information about
applications
turner parish councils don't necessarily
always have
when they discuss applications all the
information
item four is agreement between only the
agenda between parts one and two we have
no part two on the agenda
item five urgent matters
information brought forward with the
position of the gender line nothing
urging
i don't think if the planning manager
hasn't okay
okay
six on the agenda is public
participation
we've had 18
18 requests to contribute to the public
this morning to the various applications
there are four
down to speed to the first application
this morning which is the landscape of
cleveland road there are three
down to contribute to the
application
for the land at the rear of ambulance
lane
there are four down
for the halls where the application at
windmill room
there are three listed for coversat at
diddy railroad in april
to speak
and there are four down to speak to the
cleveland cleveland lower cleave
application in northern it's 18
altogether a couple of them are
statements to be read out by the
planning manager
right we move on then to item
7 on the agenda
planning applications
the information recommendations and
advice contained in the reports
are correct at the date of preparation
which is more than 10 days in advance of
the committee meeting due to these time
constraints
any changes or necessary updates to the
reports
will be provided in writing or order at
the committee meeting
and so we move on then to our first
application on pages 17 to 48 of the
agenda
7a application uh
land
center for the rule and
christine planning officer is going to
give us a presentation on this
thank you chairman
christie's to invite you on this one as
a member of digital attention
thank you
um
so this is a reserved mass application
for an appearance landscaping layout
scale in respect to 200 sensible
dwellings
um an associated infrastructure um
including the access
has previously been approved
site is online in red and then the
blue land
is
[Music]
and then
this
is an aerial photo um showing us
the actual site hatch
looks like these
uh this is the entrance looking west um
it's an existing entrance but it's also
the approximate location of where uh the
roundabout which was already approved
would be located
on the direction please
like
this is
within that gateway we're just standing
outside uh looking at pipeline farm in
the background
let's type these
this is a view outside little road
entrance looking north uh there's
another one here um
effectively there is
being obtained
it's those entrance and an advisory
management works to this we can subject
to a tro separately
next slide please
this is a view outside the listening
mode entrance looking south towards
lisbon
since within that entrance uh looking
across the entirety of the site you can
see phase one and then in the far
background
phase two and then be on the hedgerow at
the very very end uh
is this building effectively inside
please
this is uh from down
bottom of the site southwest to the
southwest corner
that's where the school and the
attenuation points will be cited inside
this is looking towards space 2 and the
actual farm in the background
next slide
this is if you're looking towards
southwest side again um
this is looking north west towards
south this is looking towards the north
pleasant road to the side
it's nice to see the land is quite
sloping
to show that very well but
it's from the top of the site looking
into the secondary entrance uh or
outside the second direction so there's
three entrances a main round about a
secondary influence which is further
along cleveland road and then the third
entrance which is on that listening road
as he is looking towards furniture
standing outside the secondary entrance
uh
sorry if that's confusing next slide is
and then this is from inside the
secondary entrance northwest that's the
valley road and
um so this is just inside the secondary
entrance
[Music]
and then
this looking in the other direction and
north east and so you've got
beyond that um
an additional field and tax health
storage and then
some sites central building trees next
slide please
this is from
north of the south central looking at
the south with five part farm in the
background
looks like this
uh i think from inside the north eastern
field uh
[Music]
these um so it's quite a big site so
it's kind of happening
to
um to give you an idea of the layout
plan so and this shows
the primary entrance which is around the
bathroom and that uh entrance there's
also a little road there you can see the
school area
and there's a vehicle which sort of
comes down through and then it goes down
the south side and that
[Music]
and then this one is
it shows the secondary entrance
um
there's some distance uh
between there and the cleveland road
between the housing there's brilliant
stuff away along that such northern edge
we're trying to wear
across slide please
this is basing plan so although we have
two applications in phase one and phase
two closing plans actually in three
phases and the reason being is that it
enables the spreading of infrastructure
including affordable housing uh started
that service
inside
scientists
this is the affordable housing layout um
so it's showing
how that's spread about the entirety of
the site
cyclings
and then this is the proposed drainage
capture areas so
um
the areas in
i think so that's pretty much the
western side of the site which we
captured in the attenuation point um
the south west
and the areas that line in blue
which is central in there
and then everything else is referred to
and the attenuation funds um
[Music]
south central within that site uh
there's a parking station and that takes
the final two
articles
um
[Music]
and this shows character areas there's
three character areas
blue main um purple
obviously that secondary sheet maybe and
then green edge and green but these are
showing better in the next one which
details
know mainstream mentions through green
edge and that's an idea of what they
would look like
next slide please
so we're gonna run through um
the house types and it's got to say and
i'll just make sure
through them almost like a side and
slideshow
um
and this is the materials plan and
materials as you see marcus report
to be um
as you can see changing colors
there's a variety of materials on the
side and as well as
sort of these display for many three
scenes
i believe the next i should hope
[Music]
[Music]
then the next one should hopefully show
the key
um
[Music]
in terms of um brick you've got a riser
there
um
issues building quite strange uh so
we've got one freestyle we're building
there which is
a
black block which includes um eight one
legend plants
and you've got
some two and a half story houses
um in other words two still houses with
foods in the roof um
you've got some two-story houses and
there's some characters which is
[Music]
this is the glasgow master plan um
do you want to read that but um
we've got a bit more detail
in red i've highlighted these areas
so you've got a lab
there
and then showing the three-minute cycle
way behind cleveland
by
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
lot of soft landscaping to advance
properties uh with a mixture of close
boarded uh
fencing delivery is in general
um
slime please
this goes around the school uh split
path so that travels around the school
site with the attenuation
on
to the sound this is the southwest
corner of the site and spiders
i've
um
[Music]
that's like this
shows boundary treatments so there's a
variety of bacteria with some scientific
ruling fencing um
device effects in fact uh defenses
include
[Music]
uh so heteropoles the statement
next slide please
um so this is an illustrative plan uh
it's not a plan that we are proving um
but it gives an idea of what the county
council can achieve with the money
that's already secured in section 26 um
for psych highway works uh to link the
proven to sonic away into the existing
[Music]
so it gives us an idea of uh what's
being moved and what's been contained
there is a significant amount of petrol
to maintain uh some petroleum
right so that's the the exact
[Music]
so these are material practical
situations
uh in general terms of answers you're
only considering allow
skeleton and external appearance and
landscaping
there are some slightly uh other points
that are raised in the surface
including some of the conditions which
require discharge at the surfaces phase
my recommendation is for approval
subjective conditions
and it will pass back to the chair to
speakers
thank chris for the
presentation
i should have mentioned just before we
started the
applications and i mentioned the
speakers for today
that the order for speakers is as
follows
and
a planning office you'll give a
presentation of the application and then
an eternal parish councillor who wants
to speak and we've not listed to speak
from town or parishes this morning and
then it's two public speakers just who
want to speak against an application
and then two public speakers who want to
speak in support of an application
and then any tourist council member from
that ward in which the application falls
they can speak then
then after that is when the plans
committee will debate the application
so all right our first speaker this
morning on this application
is andrew hockridge
speaking again against the application
would you like to come up and use the
microphone please oh i'll be right can
you hear me
[Music]
um
we've been at the farm on my part for 90
years now we've got over 500 animals and
it's quite a big business
it's
southwest of this site
so there's a lot of noise and snow we
work
we start working up as one in the
morning and actually appreciate there's
a little work to be done and then all
the noise
500 animals create a lot of slurry and
long smell
smell doesn't seem to have been an issue
with this application it just seems to
have been ignored
uh the traffic from the farm we had
eight tractors and trainers going to the
12 o'clock the other evening
and they started again up at six in the
morning this is going to be rooted
through
some of those hazes they're really going
to be happy about that
um
one of the other things that deserve to
mention
is that we stop that land with all our
young stalking cows and we run booze
with that
and there isn't there is no fencing
from to stop people coming from their
side onto our land
that we fence it stop hammers coming out
and they don't get out
a health and safety issue to stop people
coming onto our land and also for our
privacy
so
thank you i'd like to discuss that
you mr hawkins and our next speaker uh
to speak against the application is paul
white
and um
i should have mentioned to mr but you
have three minutes to address the
committee
i'll do my best i might use a minute of
andrew's time
okay good morning all um
i've i wonder whether there's more
well people here know more than
we all do because the developer has now
completed the land sale and was seen
last week starting preliminary works in
the fields so i hope we're not here just
as a regulatory ticks box
knowing what you know would you let one
of your family members buy one of these
units knowing that they cannot fully
utilize and enjoy their whole property
resulting from the known problematic
noise and smells
the committee report says daytime noise
is not problematic from an amenity space
perspective it will be when the farm
continues to operate normal on as normal
sunday and saturday and residents expect
silence they will soon tire of the noise
24 hours a day 7 days a week 360 days 65
days in a year and to think otherwise is
naive the planning committee promised a
maximum 40 db at the boundary of any
noise sensitive dwelling the boundary of
course includes the amenity space not
just inside a bedroom
it also stated residents should have the
flexibility to open their bedroom
windows it did not say that this is the
detriment of meeting a noise criteria of
40 db
therefore the presumption is that noise
will be abated with normal practice and
not a sealed box the policy dvt-13 state
noise sensing development will not be
committed when using significant noise
disturbance could arise unless adequate
attenuating measures are included by the
integral scheme
again this has not happened it's just a
ceiling box
overheating without the need to keep
windows open has not been addressed
the noise report says they are not
qualified building surface engineers and
therefore guidance will be required from
a competent engineer this has not been
addressed this is going to be air
conditioning which is again out with
sustainable requirements irrespective of
the fact that noise the boundary has
been forgotten by everybody involved and
some serious concern the amenity spaces
by future residents
following risk risk representations are
still true and should be addressed here
today
at the outline planning the developer
was given the requirement to avoid noise
toxicity and odour coming from high park
through the use of tall buildings which
serve as a barrier for odors and noise
between residential buildings and
farmland and it was proposed as part of
good practice
maximizing the use of continuous
terrorist three-story properties for
areas nearest the site with an
unextracted line of sight from the dairy
farm the continuous use of tall
buildings provide beneficial incidental
noise screening from the dwellings
behind this block and locating bedrooms
north of the development properties and
your slide here shows with three-story
buildings that's not the case
so the u-turn from the clan
is in relation to north facing bedrooms
the submitted acoustic report states the
houses in the scheme generally have
bedrooms that occupy the entire first
floor so this is not practical
the three-story units i've seen are not
contiguous and as represented in the
slight layout what this amounts to
is 155 out of 274 homes don't meet the
requirement of 40 db at the boundary
could you wonder yeah
so um so not one or two houses
fifty-five percent of the properties and
that creates to sixty without my last
two lines
if you think sixty percent of future
homeowners will be happy to live in a
sealed box and you can 100 guarantee the
farm will not be a target of daytime and
nighttime nuisance complaints when
residents move in then approve the
development if you think future
homeowners deserve more respect than
being deceived into purchasing what they
think will be their dream only to find
its sealed overheating box with an
unusable amenity space
and that the developers radically change
the developments and the promises it
gave outline don't reject it
thank you mr white
our next speaker in support of the
application is russell smith from
baltimore planet
again this is with you three minutes
once you've settled to address the
commission thank you
good morning uh mr chairman and members
of the planning committee my name is
russell smith from walton planning and
i'm the agent representing fishery homes
the applicant we welcome that the
application is recommended for approval
as you've heard from the office's
presentation these proposals before you
see approval details of appearance
landscape layout and scale
reserved by the outline planet
commission
residential phase of the development
the proposals have been subject to very
detailed discussion pre-application
discussions with the councils and
consulate seats
let's continue throughout the
application stage the final scheme
before you today is the result of many
hours of discussions and a number of
separate revisions in response to the
design feedback received
as a result i'm pleased to note that
there are no objections from statutory
consultants
since the committee deferral in march
our clients have submitted additional
information to provide comfort in
respect to the noise issues raised by
high park farms
we appreciate the concerns raised by
highway farming their response to the
application and their speech however
noise issues related to the dairy farm
considered in great detail at outline
application stage and accepted by the
council
this resulted in the council's imposing
condition 14 on the application consent
on the airline descent requiring noise
compliance statements and reserve
matters staged from short acceptable
night time noise levels
the noise compliance statements
submitted fully comprised of condition
14 by proposing appropriate litigation
measures during the night time
this includes mechanical venezuela which
is a common noise control method and
does not conclude the opening of windows
this will result in acceptable
conditions for future residents and
that's been accepted by your officers
and the environmental protection officer
overall the proposals are consistently
outlined approval granted
by the council it is supported by your
officers and statutory consultants will
achieve a high quality development with
a variety of dwelling sizes to meet
local needs to provide much needed
market and affordable housing on an
allocated site which will play an
important part in addressing the housing
supply and torridge it will provide
on-site public open space a new spine
road footpaths and a cycle route and
deliver a well-designed and attractive
place to nurture a thriving community
it also includes ev charging points to
all units with adjacent on-block parking
spaces and garage which goes above
the policy requirements
history homes have
invested heavily in bringing this site
forward it's an important part of their
intermediate immediate business plan
their technical and destruction team are
ready to mobilize and eagerly await a
start on site i therefore hope you will
agree that there is no reason to delay a
positive decision
we would like to thank torridge officers
and other stakeholders their efforts in
getting our clients off this position
there and i'm gradually all the time and
ask you to support today's
recommendation
thank you mr smith
and our final uh contributor this
morning is councillor shirley langford
his award member
hi everyone
um thank you for allowing me to speak um
i represented the south and called this
in so i thought i'd better turn up if i
could get it um i don't want to take a
lot of time and realize this is a
reserved matters application so i'm not
100 sure how much can be changed however
i do have several concerns um several of
those have been raised and you already
are aware of in the town council
replies so i'm only going to speak about
the one which was the reason i gave to
the calling
um i'm very worried about the pressure
on the road system
the valley road now gets too congested
and i would suggest it points to the um
where it gets dangerous
i know there have been various reports
stating the load on cavelli road won't
be increased but i just find that
ridiculous
i appreciate the hope is that most
traffic will come in from the link road
but there will inevitably be more
traffic using cavelli road
so that was that's my first issue about
the road system the second one
is about the fact that all traffic
heading towards littler must go through
the estate
and that worries me
um i'm particularly concerned as has
already been raised
about the farm traffic
um there are various worries about the
proximity of the estate to the farm
and we must be concerned about the
welfare of the farm but both for the
farm and the new residents
is it really a good idea for farm
vehicles to be using the new road system
through the estate
thank you
thank you councilman
right that's the the end of the public
contributions chris i don't know if you
want to
i'm sorry making some notes uh whether
there's anything
you want to add to your presentation
i don't think so this is a chat i think
if you start your discussion and then if
you want to ask me any questions i'll
try and cover them off and then that'll
be
all right thanks chris
right well for me
um
one or two issues which and i think
council language mentioned one which is
the proposed closure of the little road
junction and directing traffic through
the new estate which to me seems
ludicrous but
uh one of the things i'd like to mention
that let somebody else start the ball
rolling
yeah
can i ask a question to our highways
guys
um
when we first went to look at this
on a site visit
and we were talking about the situation
with the road and the where the entrance
was going to be down the little on the
climb road
it i thought it was said that
farm traffic and
big vehicles could still use the old
road that is there
is that right
my understanding was that farm vehicles
could use that to access the field
as one field
they would still need to
go down that road to get yeah instead of
going through the
instead of going through the aesthetic
room
um
general farm depending on where those
fields are
which farm they're going from too they
would need to go through the estate so
there's only there's only one field
um it's actually within the
application boundary that has a field
but they could still use the old road to
get them
so they wouldn't be able to join
from
i thought we i thought that was one of
the things that we were discussing when
we had the cycle
the i remember
[Music]
various discussions regarding
the exact layout and therefore the
condition that requires plans to be
submitted
although for that layout
right okay um
i'll just explain the the reason for
closing that road is that you would have
a small priority junction between two
very large roundabouts and there would
be a safety issue in which people
joining that road between
uh lots of traffic
that will increase onto valley road that
will be accelerating away from those
roundabouts in both directions as
there's one on both sides therefore it's
considered an unsafe situation if that
remains open to all traffic
okay all right can i just uh jump in
there as well you can and sean if you
could pop up the soccer player plan and
it will show the arrangement
yeah
and yeah i keep going again
that dude
this application we are not considering
access okay that's already been
concerned no no i understand that it's
been considered acceptable
the road as you'll see on there so in
between the site at the valley road so
little road
this application does not oppose the
closure of that vote that is completely
separate okay and it would be devon
county council which would deal with
that under their traffic regulations
order so
if you were to prove this application it
neither guarantees uh that that road
will be
closed or a gap or another guarantee so
that road will remain open
we had quite a long conversation when we
actually went out for a site visit
um
when this first started and i'm
sending farm traffic through to the
estate
but you're telling me now that because
of well because
that's kind of
because there's a little round about
there and there's one just just around
the corner there
people will be doing 60 70 mile an hour
when they hit that little bit of room
but i don't believe that that's
any detrimental to let farm traffic
actually go up that road
instead of going through the estate i i
think that something needs to cover up
actually i mean all right i know
we it's already
yeah
but i i'm i'm just trying to just
get in my own
mind what like what shield has been
saying but okay that's fine
now the reason that we can't allow just
farm traffic through there is i'm not
aware of any legal mechanism
that would let farm traffic through but
not
other traffic you can usually ban large
vehicles and allow small ones
but not
i've seen signs i've seen signs on
highways that that's um where cars can't
go but it's open for lorries
and so you could actually do that
never mind
forget about what i'm saying
listen to the
details about the infrastructure and
obviously the traffic movements as well
well
i'm not particularly interested in that
devon county would take the boxes as it
would do on the severe the surveys today
my main concern is
we seem to be missing the most pinnacle
point for me
is the impact on the farm
we've had no consideration of the poor
farmer family who've been severely
affected by this the fact that i never
sat at the outline planning stage in his
application now he's performing as a
reserve matters stage
um
the noise and the smell
hasn't been addressed by the authority
can we go back to slide we said that
fencing please to the planning officer
now obviously acoustic-wise yeah what
have we done to try and mitigate the
impact on the farm or both ways 100
residents potential new residents coming
in
and my main thing is
you know we're especially looking after
local economy support and local and to
me all we've done is put an alien coffin
for a high park farm
and that's my own personal opinion
because the
complaints will come in thick and fast
it's a condition where
you can get residents can't complain for
10 years give them sort of a chance to
carry on the family tradition or
basically this is going to wrap up
this this is pertinent to reserve
matters to me because this does impact
on the noise and spell
hi councilman uh thank you for your uh
question um
it might have to if i don't answer it
properly
and
please let me know and i will uh have
another go we also have giant here so i
may call her
as well
because she's uh our expert in rules and
smell however i'll give it a bash in the
first instance
um
condition 14 was included in the outline
uh that details and all this control
scheme should be submitted with this
acquisition so i think it's a little bit
unfair to say we haven't considered it
because we have in some detail and
myself janet and matt miller have had
quite serious conversations about what
needs to be done and overlay lays that
with the applicants and they provide the
scheme which we consider is acceptable
uh so
noise from high part farm has been
monitored and it's been mapped so we
know what the noise is on site set times
a day certain times of the night
um
the noise
condition
effectively requires anything over 40
decibels okay to be mitigated so
anything under that is considered
acceptable
the noise that the hype farm creates is
actually just over four deaths well so
um
measure is approximately between 40 to
50
okay a very responsive design
if we can go to the site layout piece
sean gray
one
effectively what i'm trying to show is
that just make sure you zoom in on it
so we've got um in the southwest corner
of the site here we've got a high pipe
farm which actually
labeled
can see inside the hedge
and it's probably even further south
than that
the idea behind application was to push
all of the dwelling houses as far away
as that as you can so you have
separation in the form of uh attenuation
points school site again because the
school site's not at night okay
it would be acceptable for this uh for
this site so anything
it's only over just over four decibels
and then that that's only considered
nuisance at night okay so anything that
they is accepted just one in that point
these are a very decent direction
what is the meterage from high park farm
to the boundary line of deployment
it's literally a plan but i can tell you
that isn't that far away
yes so
um is that in mind
effectively that would change depending
on what time you look at it's clearly
there's nothing
to the nearest wedding
ones that are going to be potentially
like the ones that put things in
i think what it boils down to chris is
as far as i've looked at it i don't know
what the other members think i've seen
nothing
that we that the
developer will provide to attenuate
stand along that boundary with the phone
they're
[Music]
the measured levels
vary from 46 48 46 46 43 44 and the
predicted is 50 48 that's your highest
so
[Music]
this is a serious problem and i think
just get to get big minimum houses to
shut the windows at night to attenuate
his ridiculous concept in the 21st
century
have you got my script here what
so you couldn't put something along the
boundaries so um again not normal
satisfied janet if i'm wrong uh then
please shout but you can't just put
something along that southern boundary
noise doesn't work like that okay if you
put
something on that summon boundary has to
be
a significant height because that's
lower than hypothyroid and then the
dwellings so it's actually attenuated
by just screaming that's incredibly high
and it's not actually that simple
because
sound
effectively
if you put something in between me and
casper wiseman
okay it would
block the sound but that may then
deflect off something else so it's not
as simple as just putting the screen in
and that screen would have to be meters
and meters high and
i don't know
well we can look at the
there's existing
trees there which uh are to be protected
and they're quite significant in height
but we're not relying on those for
mitigation so the mitigation derives
from the distance between the high power
farm
and then the
the
mechanical ventilation okay so what
mechanical ventilation is effectively
forced ventilation
it doesn't require the windows to be
shut permanently um they could open
their windows if they wish and on most
houses on the northern elevations they
wouldn't be instances so
may be higher
slightly higher but you still get a
vibration coming through both angles
two in front
i'm not sure i understand that but if
janet doesn't mean
essentially when you provided to the
applicants the um internal noise
standard that needs to be met
how that is met has been down to the to
the applicant and as has involved a
number of discussions uh with them
already over the course of considering
this this this application
and what has been determined is that um
that uh through um uh distance between
the noise source and the and the
properties um and the use of um
mechanical ventilation
and however given the option for the for
the residents to have the windows open
if they if they see fit and that is
sufficient and that's been shown to be
sufficient to meet the internal noise
standards given we
the the the um one of the
objectives did mention about other
options in terms of in terms of
screening or internal layout and the
afghanistan has determined that
they're not going to pursue that however
through what's been put forward that is
sufficient to meet the internal noise
standard so that um there will be no
sleep disturbance from the um uh from
the uh that the properties being there
hopefully i think it looks like
hopefully there john i think it's
this has been extensively looked at with
um measurements of the noise have been
taken overnight
and it's it's
there is
a methodology of determining how loud a
noise will be at a certain distance and
the attenuation that can be gained from
whatever acoustic treatment from all of
that it's been determined that the
internalized standards will be met we
cannot provide um uh grounds for refusal
on on noise grounds for this application
[Music]
i've got council tested next to speaking
he's not finished
i was getting through but you know you
kind of picked it up it's like a tag
team going on i think
you're going a bit distance uh janet so
i can i can i address this yeah yeah
hurry up
um what is the best practice distance
and because obviously i chose chris a
moment ago what was he imitating from
the high park farm to the nearest
dwelling and unfortunate moment that
one's going back to you say distances
but you haven't given a distance there
isn't the best practice distance of such
it's dependent on the on the noise
source and then there was a certain drop
off of noise from the from the surface
from a distant source and that's all
part of the
but that's part of the calculations to
determine how loud the noise will be
at the proposed resume
i'm not trying to get on the spot trying
to go i'm not very mathematician i just
i'm passionate before trying to say this
farm and trying to get you know
mitigation perhaps is going forward
where we can actually
work together with the new camera
going through
the planning management i've got
distance recaps from the golf so if you
want to
finish want the distance to buy this
round i'll come back in a moment
was that right
yeah but the main purpose for me is the
noise there was any smell because
nothing's been said a bit of smell at
the moment and i'm no farmer
i've been in obviously porn and bread in
the area sometimes the smell from dairy
farms that they absolutely
stink behind them
again um order has been uh included in
the initial investigation i think it was
the previous
application for this like the outline
permission that again involved
assessments of the odor and again a
similar sort of way to noise the further
you are away from the source the more
drop-off in orders there are and
the the the separation distance um as a
sufficient to to to ensure that the the
orders are within acceptable um uh
parameters at the the distance to the
residential premises
can i just come up it really saves my
skin in a moment
on that basis though about the smell you
know we've tried to
you work clothes on there have we
actually put an order of branch out to a
high park farm where i was pretty sure
our farm would be working together
trying to minimize the smell to the
residents now has there been any
financial contributions to hyde park
farm as it
uh to maybe maybe increase the slurry
pit or enclosure of a slurry pit is it
enclosed is it an open air slurry bit
yeah room i don't know but has there
been any honor branch given that because
obviously
how about farm never asked for this
event to go through now to me it is i'm
trying to look after local farmers local
farming there's in particular dairy
farming
at the moment you know crucial you know
to get the great back into britain we
need to support our own british farm
then this me isn't supporting it
me can i just come out there sean aaron
please believe me thank you
chrissy then i'll show up in this chair
thank you
sure
[Music]
and
from taking a precautionary approach
um so from the corner of this nearest
plot that you can see on the screen
now in the center
to the plan the existing planting
which is
down here
to see the green circle
is a measurement just over 150 meters
[Music]
isn't an issue that falls forward onto
this
application i think the question here
actually is one for
uh janet
with the mitigation provided if someone
was to complain would there be a
nuisance that we could investigate
or that we could uphold an investigation
on that is the key question we are not
trying not to support their partners in
actual fact local clients very
supportive global businesses and the
agents the change principle ensures that
we are protecting them
it's it's a journey of planning isn't it
because plan officers you know you get
one set of plans with three different
policies you know two or three different
views each on that policy when you say
this is
the broader impact of it all so you i
have different views to you you know
abuse your offices
can i
move on because
committee members want to speak less
than anything you need to add nature
council well i just think one more thing
jazz sorry um
whilst there are different views and
lots of planning is subjective there are
certain things in planning which is uh
what makes it quite an interesting
subject similar to geography i guess in
some ways less science so some planning
is more than art
what is subjective about um whether this
design is good etc and the other side of
the planning is a science okay so it's
an evidence-based analysis of what is
acceptable and what isn't this is more
of a scientific based project so this
particular issue is based on science we
have
in some ways the scientists here um
looking at whether this is acceptable
based on the evidence provided so this
actually isn't subjective it's based
upon evidence
i hope that helps
no
thanks
counselor chris you've been very patient
thank you um well the problem with this
one is the reserve factors
uh the outline has already been passed
yeah although i did check it was
interesting the boat back then was 5'4
it was a very narrow decision
and
the reason it was narrow was the smell
and the noise uh since then since this
actually came in of course we had a
noise
uh problem but lap house where that
application was turned down because of
the possible impact like shipyard which
was interesting
as the smell i'm sitting next door to
councillor brown who had a huge problem
with the torrent of the smell which went
on for years and started to finally
close
and we are aware of these problems that
can come up and i keep hearing
subjective we've got you know we've got
measurements but we all know subjective
if you live in biddeford every now and
again bitter food is covered in a smell
from a local dairy farm we've all
experienced it i i live quite a long way
from the farm that was producing it i'd
hate to live right next door to a farm
that was producing this but i want to go
on to an issue that hasn't been
mentioned yet which i said last time was
the most important issue when it comes
to reserve matters the school
now we've got an estate here 550 houses
we've got an estate to the north
750 houses and we're told there is a
school site on both plans we
i keep asking which one is going to be
developed i am not prepared to vote for
something where there's no
infrastructure apart from the roads and
that brings me on to the point i'm going
to make
that council and lanford raised it about
the traffic the town council has raised
this all the time
you are expecting children
who live on either estate to cross the
columbic road
to get to their school whichever site
it's on and yet when i asked about this
last time devon county
don't seem to have even thought about it
and i suggested you have a bridge
if you look on page 20
yet again we've got this nonsense at the
top there highway contributions
461 000 pounds towards the improvement
the hayward road roundabout
now when i read the supplementary
planning documents just come out about
affordable houses and we had a meeting
last week with a couple weeks ago with
devon county we were told it was up to
the councillors to decide on this
section 106 money and i'm going to
suggest we do not give any money from
this development to hayward road in fact
we've asked either for a bridge across
the corvetti road to solve the problem
we know is coming or
we ask for it to be put to more
affordable housing
i'm not prepared to keep voting for
hayward road roundabout
and i will propose that this money is
not given to people roundabout but it is
in fact earmarked for i think the bridge
would probably be most important because
there are 83
uh affordable houses on this site so i
would propose we should use a bridge
how can i come back
um so
as previously
discussed this is
reserve matters it's not what we're
going to give to reconsider section 106
within this application
or to consider what we do or don't give
money to that's already being dealt with
and signed up to withdraw the session
sorry can i come back in that because
can i ask were the war counsellors
actually asked if they wanted this to go
ahead
i wasn't the planning officer this was
that was years ago i have no idea
well you know that i bring this up every
single meeting about the scene so the
ward members need to be
part of the process it was passed at
full council and yet even last meeting
we heard that our leader hadn't even
been asked i mean what is going on
well
i'm presuming they have i don't i don't
know i can only vouch for acquisitions
that i deal with i consider that i
consult with members
on applications outside 106
i'm sorry
this is a deserved matter surely that is
a reserve matter
no it's up to us where we spend the
money not
can i ask who's saying you want i just
have one on six
yeah
this is the 106 here
it's
science
but it's been as i read it on page 19
because i was going to win this up and
play provision
that they've
applied
applicants have recently applied to
various section 106
relating to the sport provision on site
reducing the size of sports pitch from
1.1 hectares down to 0.613
with a contribution to off-site
that isn't good enough for me for the
start
but they're they're applying to alter
the 1-6 and they're telling counselor
chris that we can't vary the wrong
assist
that is uh that's correct chess and
we're just considering reserved matters
uh for this phase one site as part of
the phrase on site and as you've
discussed the
idea of the site is to push dwellings as
far away from the high part as possible
um
so this and yet chris i started to
interact with that
i don't really lose it it's not the
discussion today
apart from the play provision picture
1.1 which was agreed
at the outline stage
that was on phase two
now
now if you look at the plans that we've
seen more housing's coming down on that
site even closer to our farm
so
and we're losing
we're losing a sports pitch for no good
reason hopefully we can get more houses
so we're not necessarily losing the
sports pitch
we're losing from 1.1 down to 9.6 yeah
so
my colleague uh
is dealing with the phase 2 application
she's also dealing with the section 106
variation which relates to the phase two
and i have asked her if she's consolable
members on this variation she advises me
if that is correct
the
application doesn't suit the loss of
money so
what they've applied to do is um within
the face to
reduce the size of the pitch um so you
can get more energy into levels well
it's to prevent the pitches being
provided in the north east corner so the
flattest part of the site would be the
most logical place for the pitch and
this is that within my office report
and
[Music]
as a result of housing having to go
there um the
what the pitch effectively is on very
steep ground so it's changing from a
full sized adult pitch to a new size
pitch
which for me isn't good
can i ask for an update
on what is happening without the school
site because
the
area to the north has already got
outlines the area to the south we've
already got outlined and yet the school
seems to be sort of vague and nobody
ever talks about it can i ask where it's
gotten
where is it going to go who's going to
deal with it
we have an update from definiteness
national education i don't know if sean
wants to go through this
yeah thanks chris thank councillor
christine um i did send an update
through to all the plans committee
members in march and with regard to this
issue about these school sites and
what's being secured by the um 106's on
their different sites uh sales council
christie quietly points out two school
sites have been secured
and if members will recall from that
update
clearly only one of those sites will
come forward
and that'll be the site class actually
achieved first which could be achieved
first so for example if this were to be
refused or delayed
then maybe the other site is in board
first
devon county council have um indicated
that the
projected housing government has stalled
over the last few years again that was
in your update in march
and they also provided those details are
temporary to reduce numbers about the
actual requirement flat school or lack
of requirement platform presently
and it's all tied in close house
buildings as house completions that
haven't actually taken place yet
so they haven't committed to build a
school at all yet
yeah and yet we under our local plan we
do get 4 000 extra houses by 2031.
apparently that's not going to affect
the schools
today not you know try and branch out
the 106 etc although i've got every
single count of gritsy in the school um
so we've got confirmation from
janet williams that you are quite happy
with the way that the noises as it was
carried out and the results of it
that's great thank you for that um i
think council mcgoff's
remark about a nail in the coffin for
the dairy farmer um was a bit strong
um i'm being married to a dairy man i'll
be retired now and i live in a rural
area and yes you do get smells and farm
traffic on the narrow country lanes
um
[Music]
i was concerned about one of mr tox's
statements when he said there's nothing
to prevent the house owners going on his
land yeah
so why doesn't the farm defense of his
own land
well that's concerned about that's a
question i asked chris um what what
boundary treatments happening down there
are we putting the fence along now we
put extra planting
what is happening with the boundary of
the farmer's land along the south
yeah but he's done that
he's done that but he's still concerned
that that he's still concerned that
people from these areas could get onto
his land down there
okay so
that's happening
we're doing nothing at all
should we look at the existing boundary
in the landscaping scheme yeah
ultimately with good conditions
if necessary
[Music]
um
it's not clear can we have a little
picture sean and see what's there
existing i was
uh for myself is that the opinion that
it was quite substantial tree screening
a little bit
either way if the members reminded you
we could stop the defense
[Music]
so he could have an extra condition i
think so yeah i don't think that would
be um
so that's the existing boundary
treatment so it's quite comprehensive in
terms of um planting
the trees but on the boundary if that's
correct yeah
the whole industries on the on the site
or are they on the farms
[Music]
[Music]
more seven degeneration but in the
winter months
as that picture shows you can see right
through to the farm it's not much of a
pack
councillor brown
yes thank you chair um i wanted to go
back to the noise and the smell
because as councillor crystal mentioned
where i think i mean trying to
it was a problem and i do feel for the
farmer because and actually just went to
a high court
um the wind will take it you can't
control where i smell the noise
and i do feel that people are moving
there although they've got a choice of
windows overlord clothes
in the summer if it's hot whether people
want their bedroom windows open
in the winter in the summer whatever
don't they and really all they've got is
if it's a scenario in this closing
window
so i do feel the primer because in
torrington the factory had to close down
and that was a high quality so i don't
think that the farm
should be considered a bit more with
regard to noise and smell
[Music]
just coming back on council brown's
point the smell you are referring to in
time that was from the factory not from
an individual farm but it was farm yard
spells yes but it was coming from a
higher intensified factory not from a
single farm same smell
and
a little point about the
you know farmer's wife
no issues at all but um counselor does
live in a rural
area
this is really an urban area it's not
really a rural area at all we've got 274
dwellings going to be built right in the
backyard of it so that to me makes an
urban area that's my main point about
the nail in the coffin which i don't
trap my comments that's why my personal
opinion it's not a council thing it's my
personal
going back to the condition of the fence
and going across the boundary
for the
the applicant being obviously the
developers you know the developers just
sustained is that in their own pocket
they're the ones who've got the interest
make so much financial
obviously aware from this not i would
like to see mrs hawkins have to foot a
bill
of
putting an additional fencing when he's
already got his own boundary line and
his own problems at the moment
when i touch on the fact of the the
slurry thing
now
aussie
and any smells always going to carry you
know we're not charging weather
is there any
anything the developer could work with
mr hotbridge navy improve or insulate
or encapsulate more than a smaller
slurry but just and going back to your
scientific
well you just said a moment ago i will
raise it up
you know in my opinion yes scientific
sounds great everyone gets bamboozled
with um ball something sometimes
but
i just cut through straight daemon turns
to me you know this this is huge impact
on everybody going around though the
heavens safety wise obviously miss oprah
should allude to the fact that it's
going to go through the mitigation fence
perfect totally agree with that one
there
now
the smell of the noise is there a
stipulation where the residents new
residents coming in cannot make a
complaint for a certain number of years
and how many complaints they need to
make for actions taken by a torrential
cancer against high by far
that to me is what matters that's right
that's my
main characteristic
thank you
um
no we can't
force someone not to make complaints we
can't control you know we have to allow
people to make complaints and um again
this will certainly couldn't secure any
legal agreement to prevent that the
point is if someone does complain the
china is saying
it's not going to be considered just
language industries so
whilst people might complain
ipod farm is protected because we
because of the litigation we're not
saying it's statutes and we have no
objections about environmental
protection team
i didn't deal with the outline but i
understand that smile was considered
outlined and it's considered acceptable
i don't know if it comes out anymore
but that's that's where i'm coming from
all i i'm not an expert in those and
smell i have to take my
um
advice from strategic consultees but the
chocolatey trademasters have known if
you like i put everything together and i
make a recommendation in this case the
experts are telling me that it's not in
this instance it's fine and that's how i
presented with my testing
council craving
thank you just a reminder
i mean it's just crazy and having
considered how much it's going to
actually cost
these people with the current
electricity going up enough how when
they buy these houses are they going to
be aware
they're going to have absolutely good
electricity bills
i don't think it's fair to put people in
that position
i don't think it's right as an
environment
that's
sustainability is made up of many
tranches and one of which is that we
have to house
this is an allocated site and it
provides a significant number of values
so just the fact that there is sports
ventilation on some properties who i
think makes this site inherently
unsustainable
[Music]
green and let's say um and they could
heat as well as cool so i don't think
it's taking us back that kind of
ventilation it's necessarily completely
unsustainable when viewed in the whole
[Music]
a lot i'm going to stick my head above
the water now then um
i've seen the notes that benefit town
council supported the application with
various concerns
devon county highways have got no
objections
um with the appropriate conditions
then flood risk management have no
injections i can't really believe that
the environment agency have made no
response
um
so i'm going to recommend that the
application is approved subject to the
additional condition about screening of
the boundary with the farm
i'll second that
and so can i just is it okay
with the condition that any
[Music]
details of the condition or speaking to
the mind yeah sorry so um is it okay
that the condition is um goes to chair
and advised to agree is that acceptable
um yeah
yeah that's fine
at the expense of yeah
right and the other thing that concerned
me is as mentioned earlier
but we were told we
went at this stage and it's a junction
a little because
i'm really concerned that that's
proposed to be closed up i mean it is
mentioned in the application
that traffic will be directed through
the new estate which is ridiculous and
i'll just read because it's not very
long came to mind here from a dairy
farmer charles whitaker who sent in this
letters on our planning portal
and he says that their large dairy farm
is on the outskirts of little
and we send full arctic loads of milk
every day we use it in the region of
two and a half thousand tons of feed
stuff which comes down the a39 from
bristol rocks
virtually on a daily basis and we also
used to roll constantly
because we found approximately five
eight his hundred acres around one's
crossing oops
which produces approximately ten
thousand tonnes of cow food
which also comes into habits and crossed
back to the prohibition crust
back to our farm from habits and costs
as well as five thousand tons of carrot
slurry which we move back to that area
again all of the little enrolled
when we have busy harvesting periods
there is in excess of 200 movements a
day
we often work 12 to 14 hours a day so
we're traveling early morning at late
night
we feel it would cause total chaos
if all the constant heavy traffic was
redirected through a residential area
that's along the safety aspect of it so
whilst it's not a condition that we can
put on this application apparently
i think we should make a note that we
are
absolutely opposed i think i think
committee agreed to the closure of the
hamilton
[Music]
because it is a busy road though but it
doesn't it says occasional traffic in
the report it's a busy road
yeah and to direct traffic and all the
farm traffic that uses there through a
new housing estate i've never read
anything so rude
um i can have a suggestion as well
because presumably
presumably a
application will have to come in to
close the road um could you keep us
updated in terms of
the members
or um at least the chairman
when that application comes in so they
make comments on it or um
or view any application that comes in
because that will come into devon county
so it makes sense if matt could keep us
updated
people have concerns in this community
to
comment on any um closure
for me and as far as the school site
goes off camera
just is mentioned we're all keen on
we've been told that the county council
have no plans to build any schools in
our area
because the demographic they're wrapping
at school rules are falling that's what
that letter
that our planning manager circulated so
when we tried to pin them down and
actually starting either this one would
go along dab and hill on file on that
big sentence of the development of that
to the site there for school
they would not commit that they will be
building a school
and so actually
i can send you something for that
i think it's progressing very fast and
they have got some dates which have been
finished by which
the next few years so um i apologize
if you want to add this
that the
461 000 towards improvements to the a39
junction at hayward road roundabout
is redirected
to
a fund for a footbridge pedestrian
footbridge from this site across canada
again i can't believe it that's not been
considered in what's proposed in it
right across from this like point of
order just from the set point of order
from yourself just legal reasons do i
need to play an interest being the
accounting council for that area no
could you discuss it you determine this
application separately from membership
but straight across the road from this
side that we're discussing now a site is
under offer which is for housing as well
not the one council chris you mentioned
too this is on the tram a little bit
right at the end
so that is under offer for harrison and
again it's amazes me that we're not
being told it's proposed to put a
footbridge between those two a
pedestrian footbridge
[Music]
there's so many questions around this
place
um as chris ramfree mentioned the sexual
intersection sign is part of the alpine
commission um whilst it's in the gift of
the applicant to apply vague variation
which has happened um
where we haven't got that ability to
change those um those obligations are
set in that sign 106. um that 106 was
discussed as the period fascinated back
in 2017 i believe so it's quite some
time ago
um i think what we can do is we can
predict formal requests to yellow county
who have got control of that
particularly as a site 106 and actually
say
the members preferences um particularly
given the massive favorable roundabouts
but that would be away from the
timelessness of this application
because it's not taking our gifts
actually
okay
that's natural
[Music]
and
there's a total of nearly 3.2 million in
the milestones from
232 000 is going towards the library
library contribution i mean
i just found a mind bottle in these but
you've had the planning manager's
explanation of the 106 that's been
signed and agreed they have the
absolutely the applicants the developers
can apply to various but apparently we
can't and employed areas
we can only ask if they're considered
yeah it's different county
as i understood it um we can revisit
section 106s
under the viability study can't we
if if they
um i'm sure we were told
we can revisit section 106 the number of
affordable houses
is that right
it depends what's in every particular
one or six
so if there's a um viability review
written into a session of sales then
that'll be triggered at a certain stage
at certain pace of development so it
depends on each individual 106.
as you know that's the british
equivalent previous committees
more recently we've been putting these
diabetes into one asset
previously they weren't necessarily in i
don't know in detail this one whether
there's a viability review
like the case officer on that um but
that does
it's normally a fake appointment
development after a certain amount of
dwellings or certain percentages of
dwellings um that would generate the
build costs and profit margins how to
price etc to review to see if there's
any additional obligations to you
depending on whether that's actually
within 106
right okay
it's been moved by council a lot to
approve this secondly by councillor
watson
i do have
still concerns but we've given it a good
discussion on the issues that do concern
the 7010 the attenuation for sound
well they submitted the report which i
read through
um
and it's as it is close your windows or
switch here mechanical system and
extraction
um okay sandra can you take the book
moving separately
[Music]
penciller lock four councillor golf
against
councillor watson four
councillor wiseman
that's four four chair and five against
that position occasional
[Music]
several issues raised this morning
through this very lengthy discussion
so
i think we have to defer this
application we deferred it last time
because we had some very late
information came in on the day before
the plans commissioned so i propose that
we do defer this year we've just had a
bonus yeah we have to refuse it
but we've got to
we need to
retract that then
we need we're not retracting it it's
been determined
[Music]
i think it's going to be settled today
although both against it have got to
come up with planning reasons why they
voted against it and why it doesn't
conform with the plan
because i'm there on both sides
you're not happy with it they're not
happy with it
that's a reason it's five against and
foreign
[Music]
approval has been lost
that's not to say that there's been a
movement or resolution for refusal
it's open to the members now to
provide the reasons and policies for
refusal uh voting minuses reserve
matters application
or um equally to uh provide reasons for
deferment if there's some elements that
they believe
can be negotiated change in the remit of
the reserve master's application as
opposed to the outline um which would
then um be really important for the
application so those are the two options
members
resolution to refuse but that have to be
backed up with reasonable reasons and
policy basis to do so
what matters is being looked at as part
of that matters or to defer again the
reasons and what members are seeking to
prepare the application for
i'm sure
so we're going to defer this council
christian can i suggest the way forward
is that
there seems to be two elements why we
refuse this account i can't speak for
the council but
firstly the roads
um
the second thing is noise and spell and
unfortunately that is subjective and
i've heard
you know beside itself as councilman
goff said you either accept it or you
don't but it is very subjective and a
lot of us are very aware of these
problems and i think they're the two
issues we need the developer
needs to go back and revisit because
they've got outline this is about the
detail that we're still not happy with
those two issues i'm not sure what the
planning things would say but everyone
here has heard the arguments the
developers heard them their agents here
perhaps they need to go back and hammer
that out
yeah i mean i mean when you look at the
when you look at the plan
where this road was going to go from
little road into the new
and we'll get the answers about the
fencing we've asked for
along the boundary of the farmland phone
down there
it can come back to the next meeting and
if it's still minded that
the committee wants to refuse it they
must come
[Music]
manager
and solicitor that would defer this
to come back to the next meeting when
we've got clarification and those who
want to refuse it
if it if it's voted to refuse next time
if somebody proposes
he's got to come forward with planning
reasons for that so i'm proposing we
defer it and somebody's setting up
councillor brands set with that can you
take a vote please sign your own
deference application
thank you chair
councillor
councillor brown
councillor christie oh
councillor craigie or councillor
or
councillor against
councilman golf
four
cancer watson
councillor wiseman
seven four and
two against chair
thank you senator
okay
that will move on then
[Music]
i'm still up i'm just going to refill my
water
thank you we move on then our next
planet application 7b on pages
49
75 of your agenda
again chris is giving this presentation
[Music]
has been approved and along with social
media
and there's a couple updates on this one
so that since the officer report to
additional objections has been received
forwarded to members um
too much detail
we overlooked
and lead moorings
so a variety of um sprays that will
already dealt with the office before the
sunrise so
you know we're going to go over that
either
the agent has requested that
condition 2 is made prior to occupation
instead of improvements if members
arrived to
approve i think this is uh reasonable
um just for this condition
in the meantime
[Music]
in addition to responsiveness
development a landscape management plan
including long-term time objectives
management responsibilities and
maintenance schedules for full landscape
carriers
in small privately and gardens
and including the close facilities so
that
they should be included shall we submit
to improvement of
local kind of poverty the landscape
management should be carried out
this is the site um
it's you can see the uh atlantic highway
to the south florida's lake to the north
church
east
river storage
you know it's glory to the east and
hayward valley roundabout
which this is close to the west
next slide please
this is the
site location plan uh it quite usefully
has um boundary distances on it so if
you've never have any questions
you can zoom in on this one
and that system has been improved
starts at the north site requires the
demolition of a small piece of family
which is the garage the travel
experience is built and then as you can
see i've described it as a team of
support smaller bounty
[Music]
travels along the highway
down the southern side of the side and
under the uh clinton bridge
and all the council van
[Music]
side so this is looking up uh lions lane
which is west
next slide
it's looking down like this laying to
the east
and then we will turn around and look
[Music]
into consistent uh access approval
effects
travels similar to that driveway as you
can see
there and then it will go through the
garages between the existing buffalo and
the neighbors
looking at the northwest corner of the
site
wristbands the defense foundry uh which
currently joins family
next slide please
this is looking north
and then private is behind that fence
next side
and then this is standing looking at the
property from quite close proximity and
this is the
[Music]
first objection which was an update
which is it i believe
so this is
[Music]
a minute
[Music]
[Music]
as well
please
so this is sort of going slightly
further down the side i guess uh
looking southwest from the northern
section site
um
really just looking at a hedge
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and then um
again west uh slightly further around
the corner um
but practically the same photo next
slide
uh this is standing east looking west uh
you can see the navy property in the
background there um
um
the site
slopes uh both from north to south and
east to west and you can kind of get
that from this photo hopefully i
appreciate and as you all say it's it's
quite hard to see
what the slopes are i can assure you it
does say uh yesterday
uh this is looking east
from central on the side
[Music]
this is inside the field gateway so this
is the existing entrance to the site uh
which is off of cherokee valley you have
to effectively go up track under lingua
bridge and through there all this
without the other side um
[Music]
next slide
and then this is from traffic itself so
i
can't say photo really uh but the other
side of your gateway uh before i don't
take the game that's like this
this is under the bridge looking up so
[Music]
uh the cycle way which is uh secured by
one six would stay
in the side and then with that other
side of that
fence you can see there
and it will travel under the lingo
bridge
then next slide
looking on to this point here so
where that that sucker goes to transfer
park
this travels down
southwest this one
that's something
if you could
zoom in
you see some blue dots and some yellow
looks so uh there's a level housing uh
some uh in the form of
apartment block
um and then the others you've got two
fox sandwiches two four houses and then
the yellow which is the slightest
[Music]
um
[Music]
and this is the street scenes showing
the design of the housing
and then i believe the next slide should
go through some elevations so i will
okay so this shows how this layout and
we've got
in
[Music]
[Music]
that means
uh this is drainage layout uh so the
drainage um
effectively
all goes into combined sewer but the um
surface water would be an attempted rate
[Music]
[Music]
there so that shows the attenuation
basins
in the
top left hand corner of that you can see
where where it applies existing to us so
that's
the other side of the lingo bridge and
that's the three new cycle whereas it
follows that
slide
shows the generation places
this shows oh sorry the uh
the badger wall uh the start of the site
which is conditioned
the highway goes between which is
approved so it's between anabelia and
time so we've got um two meter high
balls and
[Music]
this
shows spanish treatments um
generally speaking okay credible
defenses around the site
sign
and then this is uh
[Music]
[Music]
these are the main considerations
landscaping and there's some additional
considerations that set out
my recommendation is for approval
subjects conditions
thank you chris
for the presentation
we've got three uh
contributors to the uh to this
application
the first one speaking against the
application is barry mitchell
well when you're setting up mr mitchell
you've got three minutes
thank you
[Music]
good morning everyone good morning
the photographs i've supplied previously
show the extent of the overlooking and
all the shadowing of honey copies
due to the close proximity of plots on
ground higher than any voltage
the photographs you've seen on the
presentation give you no idea as to the
point i'm making to you but hopefully
photographs i've shielded you
did
from upstairs of plot 18 you can see
from 50 to virtually the entire garden
of the cottage
not the small portion described in the
committee report
more importantly both views allow anyone
to look onto the patio and through the
windows and glass doors only footage
resulting in an invasion of privacy
as opposed to being very limited as
suggested in the report
the report also suggests only minor
overshadowing may occur
the photographs show the opposite
i previously requested confirmation that
the amended attenuation pond design
would not compete with my right to lay
or maintain far water subway pipes but
i've had no response
the report suggests things could be done
during the construction process
but that is not the answer i cannot
emphasize strong enough the need to
guarantee
anyone can undertake work unhindered in
the future
when the developers have long since
vanished
in a nearby estate in a civilized area
for only 26 houses
in lima's lane in a larger area than it
joins the site
there are only 13 houses
all detached with unique designs
this application does not reflect the
character of the area and has an
excessive scale opposing
the outline dedicated report states and
i quote
for consideration in this instance are
the principle of development and access
only with all remaining matters to be
reserved
i was told exactly the same in an email
from a planning officer
therefore the overall scale of this
development is your decision
wildlife reports published thus far are
misleading by implying absence of
badgers despite evidence that badge has
been on this site in excess of 25 years
the site is the only significant sized
area of wooden grassland
between durham lane and biddy food
how can digging up and destroying a
wildlife corridor or have a positive
impact on wildlife
i note in the press that your council
supports the north devon biosphere
recovery plan
not a destruction plan that this appears
to be
increased vehicle numbers moving to and
from a 40 house estate will have a
negative impact on residential immunity
of largest lane householders and on
safety of lions lane users due to the
fact that contrary to the untrue claims
in the transport statement
lyra's lane has no payments for the vast
majority of its length
none of the local residents support this
application
from their perspective the worst case
scenario is you approve it as it
currently stands
best case scenario is no development
somewhere between is a reduced scale an
amended layout option enabling a
reduction in some of the specific
negative impacts i've just described to
you for example
in the southeast corner get rid of some
plots and move others
move the play area to where those plots
were and move the palms of where the
play area was good actually to wind up
raising
certainly at the very least plot 18 has
to disappear and the plant has to move
from the outset and more recently this
development has been supported by
misleading and untrue claims
previous committees being denied the
opportunity to consider the outline
stage
due to the dubious way they call in
themselves withdrawal
there are valid reasons to refuse this
application as it currently stands and
that is what i urge you to do
please don't ruin our neighborhood by
rubber stamping that misguided and
flawed outline process
thank you
our next contribution is um
a statement an email to be read out by a
planning manager manager for mr jeff
evans
dear members of the committee
as a resident of olympus lane the
proposed development sits within 10
metres of our property
we believe that insufficient
consideration has been given to
intrusive impact 40 houses and
accompanying increasing cars and
journeys from sight to have on the
residents of the lane
the lane is narrow with limited passing
room for two cars in places and mostly
unpaved for the majority of the distance
to the proposed flight
any large increase in domestic or
commercial traffic poses a major danger
to pedestrians who have little to no
protection
the nature of the plans vastly over
develops the land in an area which is
primarily made up of a small number of
individual houses in a quiet lane and is
not in keeping with the area
kindness regards jeff evans little
meadow limers lane
are you sure
and our final speaker on this
application
in favor of it is the applicant
uh bill richardson from stronghold
you have three minutes to address the
condition
thank you chair this is the mic
and good morning members of the
committee
uh by way of an introduction my name is
bill richardson and i'm planning manager
for strongbox
a small taunton-based company that takes
pride in providing well-considered
layouts
our homes reflect local character and
avoid more standard off-the-shelf
designs often associated with the plc
house builders
we're currently building and selling
across a number of developments in
bristol devon and somerset
following a number of amendments to the
proposal your planning officer has
confirmed that the proposed layout and
design meets the requirements of the
outline planning commission
and there are no technical objections to
the scheme
and that includes from the environment
agency and other flood risk drainage
councils devon county highways
your environmental protection officer
your affordable housing enabling officer
and police architectural liaison officer
we are pleased to present a
well-considered and high-quality
proposal that provides a high level of
affordable housing and a good mix of
housing types and
sizes the layout follows the indicative
layout as granted at the outbound
planning permission stage
particular support from devon county
highways is also noted
acknowledging that the scheme will
provide an important
strategic and safe cycling and walking
group between biddeford and northern
which is below the atlantic highway
the proposal will provide for over 150
000 pounds of funding for a new primary
school in northern
although it is not a requirement of the
section 106 but for the site strongbox
is pleased to provide a play space
within the scheme as well as further
commitments to sustainable development
these include full electric vehicle
charging infrastructure across the
entire site and provision of solar
renewable energy for every dwelling to
help further reduce carbon impact
and that is above any local panel
building requirements
so finally i thank you for your
attention
and hope that you are able to favorably
consider this application that is in
front of you thank you
thank you mr richardson thank you
right that's the
last of the contributions for this
application
um
yeah um
this application uh outline's already
been passed
um
i listened to the one of the objects
there sounds like dubious uh you
yourself mentioned this in our cycles it
was an odd way if the outline was passed
as i understand but anyway um a couple
of things i was glad the idea of the
green wedge between twitter was
uh
brought
play area i don't think christian
referred to the play area but
as i understand it they don't have to
supply i've just gone to the oversea
but where they want to put it is right
next to the link road which despites me
is the height of absurdity given all the
reports on the effect of traffic on
young children's brains but can i ask
one thing when you put all the plans up
in the maps the one thing that was
missing
was the plans for the where it joins
lionel's name can i ask matt collins or
um
i've looked at the original plans for
this
where it joined diamonds lanes
see you haven't got it there either it's
not on that planet right at the top
there
yeah i've got a much bigger plan there's
a much bigger plan on our own site
but
cars like devon county actually
satisfied with the access here because
it seemed incredibly narrow
and is it two lanes going up there
because i can't see from the diver and
on my diagram there's two massive trees
on either side of the access
the
in light gray shown on the screen is
when you need to wipe side you use the
white tweezer
right the in light grey on the plan is a
three meter wide cycle way
and then in the dark gray is the
carriageway width
and so there's super width for two
vehicles to pass and go the entire
length of that road and a very wide
chair type away that way that will
continue all the way under under the
bridge
and sorry
you can't see it
i've got two massive trees on the plan
on the side
from some of the more detailed plans
i've seen in terms of
the details of the construction for the
highway
agreements that will be in place
um adequate visibility will be
provided
so i've not seen a plan with trees on
but i'm satisfied that there is enough
display
yeah i'm going to say when you say that
are they going to be chopped down or
what
i'm not aware
to be planted or existing
well the tree that is on as you as you
drive out to the site and you turn left
onto lion's lane
the big tree there isn't within the
ownership of this development and i'm
just wondering if i'm coming if i was
driving up here i'll get to the end to
turn onto lioness lane
there's a huge tree there which
they don't own so is it
what is the visibility
because we you keep talking to us about
rural areas about visibility displays
everything else
i'm just wondering about the truth
i believe that's the view out of the
site
looking to the left up the hill so
that's it
there's plenty of room to see up the
road
not if i'm coming up
that there is adequate visibility and
access arrangements
[Music]
i believe
all right
councilman
yeah
[Music]
but i think if you refer to page 55
definitely state
again
the blue dots are the
affordable houses six of them are flats
in the blue flats the three orange ones
uh shared on the ship yeah
but i can't see that that's what i would
call peppa potty through the stand
with regards to the player area i was
pleased to see that now they're going to
equip the play area
um
and i did have i do have concerns about
it being so near the road but could we
have an extra condition that the play
area is screened off from the road
either by fencing
you'll be able
[Music]
[Music]
see there's some um fencing so the idea
of that
isn't to keep people from seeing kids is
to keep the kids eating
and we could probably if we go back a
slice or
uh
get a little bit more screening between
there and the existing screening that
there is already
significant planting separating the site
from the liverpool so really
realistically unless you're keen to
cause very traffic accidents you
wouldn't be able to see down into the
significant difference and
significant screening there is two
potential planets being provided so
common factors of course this is brought
as well
any trees on site would be
protected by um
sort of intensive excavations etc
large
vehicles would be in those detection
settings
um
hopefully that clarifies those points we
earlier when it was mentioned about
reporting it should probably be known as
the architecture professor has no
objections to scheme
[Music]
i just wanted to comment and
whilst the outline's already been
determined
and that was determined in another
college district council
by another planning officer i believe
you're an agency worker
there was a calling on this at the time
and then
the councillor then was persuaded to
lift the calling because the officers
might need to refuse outline permission
in the end the agency
officer left
and another officer took this on and he
changed his mind after the call and then
so it's all right next because i think
originally this never would have
received that transformation
i believe i believe but we are we are
where we are it has got outland
permission
so we've got to deal with on that what
does concern mean is
how will that vehicles enter annually
once this road goes through that
where's the axis for only to driving
i don't i didn't see anything
um so it just appears to be just off the
assistant highway um
but again yeah the access has already
improved
[Music]
yeah
well it is a consideration that's part
of this
on the trans schedule on the decision
exits services
i wish it had shown that on on the
planning portal how they determine
that entrance will be into annually
because
when the rule goes through there they
lose the garage attached to them with it
humbly itself will be right up against
the road then with a brick wall and a
fence on top
so
i would like to be living in ambulance
where that rule goes through there
that's all
um
and to a degree
um
tide on the other side is similarly
affected although it will not be right
up against the boundary wall humbly will
be and i think we should have seen
how that will be dealt with
there but
you're going to have the room coming out
and also right next to it the driveway
cloud over there as i see it
right next to those
yes that's policy as well but again
that's you know i've inherited an online
application with various matters which
have already been approved um there's
nothing
i can do about that and actually
in general terms always saying things
i'm not just worried about the immunity
that people live in in ambulance and at
times with this road going through right
between
and also down at the bottom end
in turkey lane itself there's mention of
a kissing game
[Music]
so you can see where the highways
footpath goes under the bridge
yeah and then just to the north of that
there's a white area there which
um
somewhere bends around there's also a
little section which we've consumed
[Music]
existing access to the site
so it's just just ultimate existing
access
it showed it further generally when i
looked at it
across right across the turbine
uh traffic lane is a private road but
it's a public right way has a foot
footpath so that this effect would allow
pedestrian actors and
to allow people to continue to use that
as a as a
never even drive up there if you want
you can't drive up through there
but
that will be
prevented then
the vehicles can continue to drive up a
bit as they currently do
because it is a private road
although in very poor unmetal condition
the other question i've got
when you're finished yeah thank you
thank you councillor watson
the other question i got is the patent
cyberware will that be late
uh we're currently looking at designs um
for that and i believe the answer it
will have
yes chris um just to go back to amberley
have ambulay
objected to this
no and the
one on the other side
and
i don't know
who owned this piece of land between the
between the two then
um
yeah i don't know
okay okay that's fine and also you're
talking about knocking the garage down
so humbly must have given permission to
knock the garage down
yes it came into one side as part of the
outline so the red line area includes
anthony itself right um so
that's part of family's technical part
of the site right okay that's fine
that's fine um you know i i've gone
through this now to be quite honest
and and
i'd like to
react
because
[Music]
um
i don't know you've touched on dmo for
the impact on amenities and uh
such a large development
squash did
the presidential area
this
i resident it's the last piece of green
land which we unfortunately just given
away the previous characters just gave
it away
um there is no impact on immunities you
know from the first gentleman speaking
of mr mitchell i think speaking in the
beginning
i i believe it's your dwelling you're
talking about the survey of the
overlooking your property there well
it's not if you look your place is not
just one problem it's going to be
overlooked you know is that being
mitigated at all again it's not being
mitigated
uh that's one point the second point
being that there's been no comments to
leave from dcc when the rights away
right away they're going in check and
then i'll see is a probably right away
going there and we do have a small money
boost
nursery then at the bottom then so that
would
what's the impact on the nation that's
not that's not being taken into
consideration either
i know it's czech remains private but
the sexually
bloody boots is isn't private because it
comes into public way uh but right away
they're going through but we don't know
we had no comments from dcc on that
obviously speaking i had to try to check
on this prior to the meeting and there's
no comments being received as you can
see
and that to me is never about them it's
not again that's against communities but
in the public right where you're going
up that name and you said maybe their
access well you wouldn't want to take
away get your access to the residents
you live up to church in maine
so i think that's asking me to have a
badness but you're saying there's still
a scope for the traffic to go through
turkey
but when people get wind of the access
return from name
would it become a rapper
at the end um the check event so whilst
you could travel up you'd have to
if i was to drive downtrend lane i
couldn't drive up the line there's a
bottle up there
and equally even if the bar wasn't there
i would smash up my car because it's
important
so
yeah
um so
there's no vehicular access proposed
there and there's no at the moment the
traffic will drive up there and access
the site this is where the site access
is this closed that offensive
[Music]
to have an available on them
there's no access down there and it
doesn't impact on that if anything
it provides a benefit to them because it
provides them a safe and suitable
cycle and footwear to actually get money
boosts from the link
right now
i pushed it down quite recently
i wouldn't really want to push a down
channel right
or try to peel over place um and you
have to come across a link so
you've got two options none of them are
really
[Music]
which to me is the crux of it yeah that
is detrimental i think just mostly
resonance there no problem so that's
supposed to be mo one um
the
as of all the fun
21 meters as you know um is considered
acceptable in terms of its uh distance
to neighbours so if we zoom in
something uh the top of the cycle is
short to the north so we've got 36
meters to head time 32 meters
to the laurels
um
oh
27 meters to tanglewood
uh
27 meters there
that's the
ridge that's the point you saw
if you go down
[Music]
this is 40 something meters
and then um
you've got a cottage there so that's 20
meters but that's not really there is so
21 meters is really to rear
and that's not really to it so
20 meters is generally considered
acceptable
explain
[Music]
so um the photographs which you wouldn't
see from this little show
uh being drone flowing in the air to
approximately the location of the window
it shows the extent of this garden and
the rear of that policy
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
so
i'm looking directly this way
from
that property i'm looking north
if i'm standing here
and looking there
i'm looking for a
wall which you can't see through
so there's no privacy impact because of
the
the way that works does that does that
make sense
with the driftwood vision yeah you'll be
blocked by obviously yeah i mean
construction so yeah i do what i do
understand but is there any way that we
could rotate any properties on site to
alleviate any concerns of that
um in all honesty uh customers i don't
think that it's necessary to put this
application in is
based on the info i don't think we could
uphold reasons refusal on amenity as
with any application i do sympathize
with with the neighbours
any application
will have an impact you know you're
having a residential property built next
to you
of course it's going to happen
my job is to work out if that impact is
significant or severe okay in this case
for a variety of reasons i've said it
after
the impact isn't severe and significant
so
yeah
well
as i say i don't think there is a
significant or severe impact
that's
that's check can't you get one more
think this um
this relates to quite a lot of
developments now um we're coming in on
this is a general oversight from the
center net and so obviously directed to
sean anders and stacey with the unique
representation without
surely the council of the council of
councillors could challenge
obviously you go to a judicial review
because obviously where is that within
the beginning
doesn't seem to be very transparent
in my opinion
i'm not trying to train anyone on a bus
i just doesn't seem to be but all these
everyone planning is going through
discussions that matters and yet the
outline plan in the beginning seems to
be a little bit forward
surely you can challenge or we'll go
back and not even refuse our application
in entirety
but can you not am i just making things
up here that's just why it's worth it
yeah
i think the first thing to say about the
allied planning commission is that um as
we're aware the
member at the time is no longer a member
and the officer at times
council
i certainly haven't seen any documentary
evidence about
any concerns about how that was
determined or the
delegation of examination um
i've heard hearsay but that is purely
all that it is i've seen no evidence
about any concerns there
and in terms of a judicial review um
we are way out of the period of judicial
review
station may be able to confirm how long
that is
six weeks from the decision yeah
so it is just back in
yeah sure i think i think michelle the
important chinese camera is some of
these applications are coming through i
mean i can't excuse you with the schools
etcetera you get these big outlet
planning applications coming through we
should maybe pass some previous councils
and you get fresh characters coming in
freshly look at it fresh new ideas new
representations from the members of the
public
um
can we not challenge as an authority so
actually no we think with that authority
at the time made a mistake it's not
being
nothing's been developed because
obviously they're going to land them to
get the maximization of the house sales
going forward you're never going to
release a 400 and have a site straight
away because the market actually dropped
you can get the value you want for
making money on it so you're only ever
going to release 67 properties at a time
and this is why we've got the land
blocking issue within torridge and then
where we can't
deliver a five-year land supply because
developers are actually they're that
pocket
we wanted to bring it on for ages to
maximize your value market but how can
we challenge you i'm planning to correct
it no we can't
not at this stage not on this particular
application
um
we've got to deal with it with the
outline permission that's been granted
and that's what we're doing and i mean
there are some things
on this application that are
beneficial
it's the first site i've seen that's
providing solar panels for all the
houses
photovoltaic panels and it's the first
one i've seen that i've electric um
electrical electrical vehicle charging
points
so
a lot has been said about the sideways
way down through but actually you can
now recycle down
or walk down limestone and we don't
joking to get to the same destination
but um this will be a formal
cycle footwear down through the other
issue that i think on the objectives
raised was
they've got foul drainage from from
their
site i think it's church and cottage
and i see that there's a condition in
here
that um
it mentions that
7.4 a neighbor adjacent to the proposed
attenuation system
notes that they had a covenant to
discharge their septic tank
into the field and it's likely
the soak away is in this location
ultimately
this is a civil matter however
uh the planning agent has included a
maintenance corridor for assumed
existing services
in addition it's been advised that if
this system is uncovered
it will either be redirected where
feasible or connected into the combined
sewer
this is acceptable for the purposes of
this application so
should that happen i think that's why
the two attenuation ones have been
separated for this
where it's assumed that this fight comes
out from the german cottage
these are crates in the ground now
the attenuation system
crates in the ground with the
shallow
pond floats on top
yes
right i mean there's the amenity
language land is going to be affected
because there are no footpaths
and we're picking up on council mcguff's
issue
we're stuck with the outline that was
granted a few years ago now
um
there isn't there aren't any footpaths
to the site
when the outline was granted by the
applicants
and it will have
an increase of traffic into lines there
quite a big increase in traffic but
access is already determined at their
united states so
we stopped really well our horns and
then you know those who
don't think it should have been granted
in the first place
so unless anybody else wants to
contribute to it
i won't recommend that the application
is approved because some of the major
concepts got the objections so i
recommend approval as per the officers
[Music]
um
[Music]
don't matter
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
counselor
that's a bad tool for councillor brown
or councillor christie or councillor
craigie or councillor leather or
councillor four councillor mcgovers
against councillor
councillor wiseman
four
that's eight four and one against the
grant and chair
thank you
on pages 76
109.
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so go on to the location plan
say this is the location pound the side
part lined in red
and this right is approximately 3.47
hectares in size and comprising the
three agricultural fields
next slide
this is the vacation a little bit more
detail this is an arrest location fan
despite quite light and red um there's
an annotation on the other side location
um as you can see from the image the
site is within sort of approximately 400
meters to the west of wholesaling
windville road the a3027 runs adjacent
to the northern boundary of the site the
lay by to the northwest boundary
and the site is bounded to the south by
the line of the northerly
railway line which serves part of the
roadway cycleway which is designated
part of the national cyclone network
the next slide this is the satellite
image the site is indicated in red as
you can see the image um from the site
that the scientists within the open
countryside they're located to the west
of conserving
and the east and south and west family
consists of agricultural land
so the next slide is just another
satellite image again with the light
slide out in light and red um the bank
isn't slightly just getting annotated on
just to be a little bit more clear where
windmill road is to the north
and the site is founded by the south
blue line which says part of the ruby
way which is to say is the designated
washington cycle network group
and access
across the highway is a public footpath
shown by the dashed orange line
and then
bounded by cultural
fields
um so just before i move on to the
photos um i thought we've just used
which are my members of the proposal
so the application is seeking full
planning permission for restoration of a
nuclear bunker to provide a new tourist
attraction and the change of use of land
for stationing of 45 holiday lodges
the number of lodges have been amended
during the course of the application
from 49 to 45 watches and that was due
to the need for an on-site attenuation
basis
so this is the proposed site plan the
proposal includes the closing up few of
the existing access points into the site
and the creation of a new access point
to the southwestern boundary of the site
onto windrail road
in addition a new footpath is proposed
to be created from the isis inline they
buy into the site and onto riviera
southern boundary of the site
so the next slide is just slightly
zoomed in just to be a bit more clearer
for you so um as you can see there is a
new athlete for access point to the
southwestern boundary and the hedge bank
is to be translocated back to provide
the visibility display onto that highway
also you can see the new footpath to be
provided which is indicated from the
cream color which will link from the
existing lay-by onto window road and
leads into the site proposing as a link
onto adjacent ruby
way cycle path which i think you can
just see to the bottom of that photo
and there's the indian plan shows a
proposed reception building which will
consist of a large building
so just on to the next slide this is the
site of the existing nuclear bunker and
the more observational posts
the sex slide
the agent has provided elevation plans
of the existing bunker
so those are it um during the course of
the application um
we have requested plans and details of
how it's proposed to restore the
easiness as a sort of tourist attraction
um the agent has not provided many
details advised that in the event the
application is supported they prefer to
submit these details
condition
so next slide is moving on to the photos
i am aware members sending a virtual
site visit last week so i have a very
clear understanding on site however i
quickly run through some photos just to
remind members um so this is a photo
listing easter egg in the slight more
east and you'll see the holes level in
the background
so the next photo is looking west um
i've been to the site
and the next photo again is looking west
so the area beyond where the proposed
lodges are to be installed
this is the north east of the site and
as you can see it was where the world's
spatial posts and cold war bunker um
which is seeking to be installed
um as you can see this is the secret
settlement
in the background
um so as advised um
on my virtual cycles interview last week
the bunker has actually been sealed with
sharp health and safety purposes um so i
did go back to the agent and ask if
there was any photos of the bunker um so
the agent has sent me some photos of the
bunker so this is just to show what the
book consists of so essentially it is a
single room
um and obviously you know we can see
that that that's what's proposed to be
used as a proposed tourist attraction
so uh this is just reviewing the
observational posts and the access point
of the
bunker this is the photo
west side um
to the west is like little east then
this will see again that holds up in the
background um the next photo
is um
[Music]
nuclear bunker zoning post on some west
side again see that this deepest part of
the site
um this is basically taking a southern
boundary
[Music]
this is a photo looking to the east of
the site again the proposed modules will
be installed along um this elevation
and this is the photo the southern
boundary again so something to the left
of
[Music]
[Music]
network
so this is a facial the northern
boundary which
runs is to the normal badging site and
you'll see that the
site is just along the left right hand
side there
another facial northern foundation i'm
just across the road from windmill road
again it's just a big view in terms of
the site and looking at that site um
making those proposed knowledges
um
and this is another photo which just i
think you can just sit down there just
to sort of say members are aware of
where that line by ours and know where
that pedestrian footpath is to be
included
so i have introduced some people it's
only landscape vision impact assessment
which was submitted um
with
the application
says say the site is indicated in red i
don't know if you can see the yellow
angles of the ufo positions where the
photos have been taken from so if we
just very quickly run through that
see some of the more direct ones i think
i've already covered but i just thought
i would go for it again so that's the
first few points on windmill road which
has been included in my site photos
so the next few points is further up
windmill road and obviously they line
the flipped past four
and then another view looks down on the
neighbor on the left
and then another view of the
neighborhood
and this is a panoramic venture the site
from wilmore road you can just see the
bunker in the top
hand side there and that just good photo
in terms of that panoramic view sorry
sean
i'm not trying to catch you out and this
is another feature of the north eastern
corner of the site
and then another photo looking from ruby
way which we've also done
and then photo looking into the south
east of the site from rooney way
and
then the photo from church lane
and then the next stage home
is from the hospital the path right away
and then the next viewpoint is from
church lane as you can see these are
slightly further away um just to kind of
get
further away in terms of kind of looking
at visual impact
and then the next viewpoint is from
saddam road and you can just see the
site annotation in the top there
and then the next few is from
panama road
and then the next viewpoint is probably
about three kilometres from the western
side so that's from ryden lane
and you can just see the site annotation
with that black line there
and this is the road from the near the
whole serbian agricultural shave ground
um as i'm sure members can see from my
report the ldaa has been reviewed by a
landscape consultant who has concluded
the proposal would bring
uncharacteristic evidence into the rural
farm landscape
i think i think we can see here the
effects would be normal within around
one kilometer of the site that would be
less noticeable than beyond the liquid
area i think that's fair and that's
what's shown here
so just moving on to the proposal so
this is an elevation drawing of the
bouquet's large um
so each launch will provide
self-contained holiday accommodation
there was a question i think from lock
at the virtual site visit to ask saying
if the lodge has met the definition of a
caravan i have spoken to agent he has
advised that the closed lodges are
designed to meet the definition of the
caravan
so the agent has advised the dodge
columns with wheels on and then the
wheels are removed when on site
each launch is able to move by road and
does not compromise on more than two
sections which are bolted together
the overall height is 3.05 meters but
this would not include those around all
the skirting around the edge of the
caravan so when that the base of the
veranda is included it would be 3.8
meters
and the caravans rest of the concrete
base under their own weight and
six holding down eyes
so the next slide just shows the
proposed floor plan of the lodge
and then the next slide is an indicative
base can section to demonstrate how the
lodges are to be attached
to the base and held the services to be
connected to each lodge
and the next photograph was just an
indicative photo of what the agent sent
me in terms of what the holiday lodges
are likely to look like
um so we next have a couple of
cross-section drawings um demonstrating
the launches being stationed on the land
they're quite small i don't know how
helpful they are to you but so this is
section j and h
so this cross section is the view from
mill um to windmill road
so i don't know if you can slightly zoom
in and say jj you see j and h
say that so you can slightly zoom out
again sure that would be that cross
section there showing those branches on
the site
um and then the next cross section
um
would be so a and b
a a and b d um would be again from
adjacent to the windmill road
and then c d
would be the cross section of lodges
from the southern boundary from taking
rooney way
and then the final cross-section drawing
is an e f g
and that's from the southern boundary
again moving into the cyclone
way that just kind of gives you a bit of
an indication of the lodges sat on that
land
okay so just getting onto a little bit
more a couple more plans just to kind of
give mothers a little bit more um some
background in terms of because i've
constructed the site so the historic
environment um and this is within one
kilometers so the whole zombie
conservation area is annotated by the
blue line
slightly
which is obviously around the
core of the town
[Music]
the agent or applicant has provided next
slide a landscaping plan so this
indicates the trees to be retaining site
there is a hedgehog to be replanted
where the new access goes to the south
um
north of the boundary of the site
and to provide adequate visibility the
plan that show some landscape offering
to be planted along the normal elevation
and there is additional trees as you can
see to be scattered around the site and
the papaya's subspecies to the south
will have natural planting around the
boundary of the attenuation basin
so next slide
is to the left is the environment agency
flood map showing the whole site within
plus zone one
and to the right is the clarification of
the site using a proposal drainage area
and then a substrate japan which is
proposed to manage surface water runoff
comprising of on-site attenuation basin
um and the foul drainage um is to be
connected by veins
so just moving on to the tanning
considerations um of the uh proposal i
know as i'm sure have read my report i
just thought it would be useful just to
pick up on some points so the principle
of development
so the president is seeking to deliver a
new tourism attraction on the nuclear
bunker and tourism accommodation with 45
and safely contained hyundai dodges
as stated in my report there is concern
relating to justification of this
tourist attraction
the proposal has been submitted as
evidence to demonstrate there is the
desire for the nuclear bunker to become
a tourist attraction or this would be a
popular attraction
equally there has been no details
submitted in respect to the restoration
of the old bunker and how that would
look like
so during the course of the application
i have requested details of how it is
proposed to be to restore this to the
tourist attraction and they have not the
agent hasn't been able or willing to
provide those details
um in considering the detail of the
tourism proposal policy dmo 18 is set
out of the report which is relevant this
policy determines a range of
qualifications for tourism accommodation
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
on the site as there is no
existing tools and accommodation
established on the site
therefore the principle of the new
holiday park um
is coming to policy um
[Music]
so just quickly getting onto downside
character vision impact the application
is being compromised by the ldia
the collusion of the ldia does that
decide how it would have some effects
the landscape character but mitigation
measures have been incorporated to
lessen the impact
so we have got someone to review the
lbia um which is also in your report um
the landscape consultant who looked at
the ldia considers that the lvi hay
hasn't fully explored everything um
these bases are setting the poles were
being particularly effectively
groundworks on the side and the effect
of developmental dark night skies um
[Music]
the view of the landscape consulting is
that they will be a moderate adverse
impact um and the impact really helps
from the extensive groundworks required
the effects of the development of the
slightly more settling involves will be
in the better planting area within the
main
part of the site so i think it is clear
there is some conflict with policy
objectives set out policies sga sc 40
and gloa
8 um to conserve the enhanced landscape
character
so this moving on more quickly in terms
of heritage and archaeology
you can see the conservation officer has
consulted and she says that there's um
the heart of the conservation area is
less than substantial and in limited
views equally
historic environment has consulted and
there has been some archaeological field
evaluation undertaken and they do not
suggest that the scaling situation
development has an impact on many
heritage
assets
in terms of the residential immunity um
there's a proposal there's substantial
distance from nearest adjacent dwellings
and therefore there's no harm to the
energies of neighboring properties
the highway engineer is here so if you
have any questions for him in terms of
highways i'm sure we'll be quite happy
to take those um the highway authority
um has requested an 800 pound per
logical contribution which will go
towards improving the cycling pedestrian
facilities in the immediate area
the highway authority is satisfied at
the coast office of safe and suitable
access so it meets the tests of the mppf
blood risk and drainage um the site is
within
one critical drainage area
that's
in terms of attenuation base and hasn't
put forward the technical quantities
have been
consulted and they
are saying that those proposals are
technically acceptable and they have no
objections
in terms of ecology um providing with
the positivation measures will secure
for a length
um
there's not considered to be any
significant adverse impact in relation
to protective species or habitats
so in terms of relative economy i think
we have to say there will be some
benefits to the proposal um a tourism
need an economic impact statement has
been submitted which will cost a number
of jobs um will be secured through this
proposal
um in terms of the conclusion
um i think in terms of the benefits i
think there are a number of economic
benefits
however the principle of a holiday park
in this location is country to policy
particularly
too
and
there is considered that there will be
some downstate harm
and certainly wouldn't meet policies
to conserve or preserve and enhance the
landscape culture of the site
so in conclusion the harmful impact
is significantly want to really outweigh
the benefits and therefore
the
recommendation to you chair is for
refusal
thank you
thank you tracy very comprehensive
presentation
right
the first contributor to this is
liz lester who sent a letter in to be
read out by the penalty manager
road is a very fast road just one
carried away in each direction with
potentially over 100 cars entering and
exiting this site it will add to hazards
already there people are holidaying on
this site are likely to chat with views
and other resorts rather than stay in
hellsworthy
whichever way they go they were actually
already very heavy traffic through a
small town with two pinch points making
pedestrians vulnerable
although there is a plan for a footpath
to the town it will be a long walk and
will probably not be used
this is outside the main town of
hillsborough on greenfield land and will
add nothing to the local community all
the businesses within the town
thank you sean
next contribute to speaking against his
lindenpaper
and control
thank you chair and thank you for the
chance to speak uh my name is lyndon
piper i'm a lifelong culturally resident
and wholesale tank counsellor
possibly is an unspoiled rural market
town its position in land from the
moving north cornish coast does provide
opportunities for high quality low
density tourist accommodation however i
vehemently believe that this should not
come in the form of caravans perched on
a prominent hill in full view of the
town with no supporting activities on
site this to me is the lowest quality of
tourism accommodation fine in the right
spot but not in a location with no
adjacent tourist offering
our town is shaped by two beautiful and
deep river valleys which are abridged by
our two iconic listed viaducts
beyond is a rolling pasty land which is
our the lifeblood of our town and our
most valuable assets this development
breaks that natural boundary in the most
hideous manner the town and stanton road
is clearly visible from the site
therefore the site is clearly visible
from the town and stone road
no rambling bia is required to establish
that
furthermore the awkward relationship
between the caravans and verandas and
the natural topography of the field is
clear to see in the submitted sections
and layouts
veranda's several metres out of the
ground and caravans dug into the
hillside
clearly demonstrate the clumsy and poor
design and unsuitability of this steep
hillside location
connection to the town is poor the
church lane footpath is boggy eight
months of the year unlit and steep and
open to livestock and floods at the
bottom several times a year
the a3072 is scarily fast and totally
unsuitable for holiday makers to cross
or walk along
they offer an internal footpath is
insignificant a short section of grass
verge could be improved to offer the
same benefit
there is no tourist attraction on the
site
the application includes nothing
substantial in how
the bunker may even become a tourist
attraction
i also have some doubts that the
windmill which was taken over taken down
over 100 years ago leaving no trace will
create much of an attraction either
we have excellent opportunities for high
quality tourism accommodation in and
around holsworthy the crawford lakes
expansion is a significant development
in our locale
they extend permission for 60 lodges in
a valley location one kilometer off the
ruby way at simpson valley fishery i am
sure will come to fruition at some point
a well-considered and attractive
proposal
45 caravans patched on a prominent hill
is not what our town wants or needs
no amount of lengthy consultants reports
will change this
the boom in staycations and migration
out of the cities provides an
opportunity for prosperity to come to
our quiet corner of devon
let's please not sell out early to low
quality tourism accommodation in an
inappropriate location
the application that could make no
significant changes to the plans
following the pre-application consultant
consultations
the application is totally attributed
with planning policy both paris councils
are strongly and unanimously against the
application and valid objections have
been raised by locals
i do not see any substantial benefits to
the tax i am sure our experienced and
elected councillors will back up this
viewpoint
thank you for the for giving me the time
to speak and represent our time
thank you council panther
[Music]
can you take a vote that we
passed three hours please yes thank you
chair
council about him four councillor brown
councillor christie
cancer craigie or cancer leather
cancer a lot
counseling the goth
wisely
thank you sandra chair just before you
proceed can i just ask for a point of
clarification the gender who's just
spoken was he speaking as a member of
the public already speaking on behalf of
officially involved council you're a
member of the public under the public
speaker in support of the application is
in struggle
[Music]
thank you
and members of the committee
my name is ian strutwick the applicant
i am a devon based
and specialise in new holiday
accommodation and the tourist economy
across devon i'll be talking in favor of
the application
as you know the application proposes 45
high quality lodges these will be of
natural wooden assimilate into the
landscape and fall within the legal
definition of the caravan
we chose the site because of its
sustainable location
close to horseworthy with its footpath
linked to the town
its immediate proximity to the ruby way
the entrance to the movie way and the
existing on-site heritage asset
it really is an ideal touring base for
visitors to the area
my vision is to provide a high quality
holiday accommodation which has been
landscape-led in its design and layout
with low-level lighting all of which can
be controlled by planning condition
the site will be beautifully landscaped
our detailed proposals are to enhance
what we already have with native trees
hedges and banks
we will restore the world war ii
royal observer corp monitoring outpost
which is an undesignated heritage asset
into a modest but important visitor
attraction
and currently people trespass on the
site break into
the outpost in order to visit it
we will provide a new footpath through
the site linking the ruby way to the
existing public right-of-way into
holdsworthy this will be of benefit to
the local community
very importantly we consider that the
application is policy compliant
local policies allow for new development
of this type that is related directly to
existing tourism features
those are the council's own guidelines
on dm18
ruby way
is an existing tourism feature
and support the economic development in
rural areas through employment growth
and job opportunities
our proposals do both of these things
the proposal will generate 2.7 million
in local expenditure per year
the park will therefore directly provide
seven full-time employment jobs in
holesworthy two full-time employment
jobs in tibetan which is where i'm based
to 2.5 ft
fte jobs in
the cafe at the park entrance it would
indirectly create 45 new ftp jobs
locally
the positive financial impact on the
whole
the town the rural community will be
significant
i hope you agree that my proposal
presents a strong opportunity to deliver
a new and exciting asset to hallsworthy
that will have a very meaningful
economic impact
that far outweighs any of the negatives
thank you very much for your time
thank you
mr thank you
our final contributor to this is
councillor james
board member
um
part of the site is in holesworthy part
of most of the site is in polls with the
hamlet's
coacher heppel called this application
in
and he's unable to be here today so i
drew the short straw
i'm not going to spend three minutes
going all through everything that's in
front of you what i would say is that
there is particularly good arguments
from the term council and from my
parish which is holds for the
inhabitants
to the reasons for objections
um i don't as i said i don't want to go
re-run everything you've got it away in
front of you
i support of the officers report coach
heckles calling the comments from
i will leave the town council though but
i must support the um from the hamlets i
was at the meeting when it was described
as a plot on the landscape it is you
know um
well built up like it is but what i
would say is that so often we hear from
parish and town councils that they don't
take notice
of the comments they make and as i say i
thought they were first-class comments
um i have concern about the
interpretation of dm18 but that's
stanford officers not for me
and also
it was something else but i'll leave it
at that because i should have been in a
meeting at 12 o'clock so thank you very
much
right that's the last last of the
contributors who want to start the ball
rolling on this
road
[Music]
because the application has far-reaching
elements other than those of the royal
observatory we feel we cannot give
general overall support to the
application
now i cannot see this letter on the fan
portal nor can i see a copy of it on the
design and access statement so where
they got that from but i do have great
concerns with raw observable
comments
also devon county council highways say
they are happy with the designated
parking area for the tourist attraction
so
can you put on the map where this actual
designated
parking area for the tourist attraction
is
initially
is
do you want to come do you want to
hammer
can everyone hear me or would you like
to sound like a bingo caller
so
um probably like everyone else i was a
little bit skeptical about the whole
nuclear bunker thing i did speak to the
transport consultant who clarified that
effectively
and my understanding is that um it's
going to be almost like a plaque um an
information board that you just go and
have a look at and i think on the
comments it's been submitted i think it
is on there they are online
but effectively it's going to be more
for people on the site or even passing
people on the ruby way rather than
actually expecting to bring a lot of
people in
i get that
i don't think i've been there apologies
but i don't think i've been in rush to
go there too um as part of a tourist
attraction so effectively what they were
saying is they were going to incorporate
the parking around the reception which
is the
southwest
um as part of where you effectively park
to register and also that will double
this um parking for the um tourist
attraction as well
um and and given what they are offering
i
accept that like i said it's not going
to attract a lot of video traffic
outside of the um
outside of the development
what we've got right there then can i
ask one more question about highways um
initially you asked for a contribution
of 50 000 pounds to work on the replay
yeah
later you say that the cost of such
improvements works have increased
but in your third response the second
paragraph you're now happy to accept 800
per lodge which is only 36 000 pounds
yeah i think they came did they come
down i think first of all they came down
a couple dwellings anyway so it was
going to be 40 000 pounds
um but when you discuss um one of six
agreements there is a degree of horse
training there effectively the original
thousand pounds we asked for was akin to
uh what we've been asking for dwellings
and holes in the area for upgrading the
ruby way the argument was put forward by
the applicants or the
agent on his behalf
was um that
they should be paying as much for
tourist traders as a single dollar ship
so like the caravan should pay less um
and after much negotiation we agree
that's probably fair um so rather than a
thousand pound per unit it was a
[Music]
that was very interesting what mike said
about um
it being a tourist attraction but just a
board
a board stuck up on top of the thing for
people to say oh yeah this is
this is the bunker my understanding is
you know for example you walk from the
civic center to castle mountain there's
there's like an information board there
isn't that it's good there is going to
be something to look at but that's going
to be part of so effectively what the
agent will say is it's
um i was almost expected originally and
i think that was my comments it was
gonna be like a ward of tunnels where
you found remnants of the third right
that kind of thing
um apparently it isn't couldn't be quite
like that it is gonna be something you
look at but you know and i said just
just have information
but the thing is there is no tourist
attraction there and we're trying to
create a tourist attraction so that they
can have the 45 lodges
but
am i right tracy
that's not in our policy i mean it's an
interesting one because it's all fenced
off it can't be an existing drawer of
attraction it's all fenced off
you can't have it both ways exactly um
so the proposal is clearly shirtful to
describe the restoration underneath the
bunker to create new tourist attractions
also also i i picked up that in one
place
in the tourism need an economic input
impact strategy on page 13 he said
it will support 45 local jobs
to create this
tourist attraction and where obviously
people will be working at the logic i
don't know
but but i i'm just
i
now have seen what what's inside it and
i don't believe
in my my opinion is that that's how it
looks now
inside inside that
little bunker it's just as just a little
room
you know and so and also
i read where he said
there is about 80 000 people who will go
and go around looking at these things
uh you know they're like i think some
sort of society 80 000 people
how many people's going to rock up there
and with cars and there's nowhere to
park then
79 000 79 000 yeah thanks but when you
look at it when you look at that
where will roses
had it about where to park and now they
just want that little bit of parking
down the bottom left-hand corner where
you go in for what one two three four
five six cars
right
and and
there's supposed to be all these people
coming to look at it and i can't believe
that everybody on that side who's going
to want to
rock up there and and go and stay in one
of the things things it's purely wanting
to go and see it
but something
if you want to call it the book
i you know according to what i've been
told through people who are in australia
one one person said to me we used to
come play in that thing as kids until
they kicked us out and all it is is a
little square room
so i'm i'm going to propose that we go
with the officers report and refuse this
application
yeah okay
the first thing that struck me when we
had decided it was a prominence yeah of
the sound very prominent i think and
just picture
of all the
all the
um
works that needed to be done by a
dictator to begin
um
well it's been proposed
to refuse our settlement to refuse
yes
[Music]
minutes
[Music]
okay our next application is application
d seventy
uh corporate did he run road in apple
door and
sarah
sarah was taking this one thanks
thank you chair so this application was
subject to a site visit um so some of
the photos are records of what you saw
on the site visit so
this is a
venture of a detached dwelling for open
market
and it's four bedrooms um this is a
resubmission so the previous one um in
2021 was was withdrawn so if we go into
the location plan
[Music]
so this shows um the location pound so
it's outside of the development boundary
it's off diddy well road um it's also in
the undeveloped coast so policy sto9 and
you've got commodo in red there and then
obviously to the
north and west is in blue so that is a
paddock that is also in the applicant's
ownership
so this is just a satellite image of the
location just to show you kind of the
locality um and kind of the built form
that that is kind of sporadic within
within this area
the site is
occupied and joined by
open fields um the nearest property you
can see there is to the north east and
that is
so this is just showing you the um
access so this is taken from the north
east so the dwelling you can see is um
and then the next slide
this
is from the highway with with the
existing access
so this is from the southwest so looking
from the other directions of this um is
kind of part of the rear of um
looking back at the access
so this is the access itself and you can
see the existing driveway and then
obviously the the adjoining fields and
then on to the boroughs in the
background there
so this is um the driveway itself so
this is looking north west and the site
is just slightly um to the
north north east there
so
so this is the um
part of the site so this is from the
existing access looking to the kind of
north um and north east and that's where
the dwelling is to be located
so this is just kind of looking a bit
further around so you can see the access
there with the highway
and that is looking primarily at the
site
so this is looking from kind of the
bottom of the driveway looking back up
so that is the access there so you've
got copper soda on the right and then
the new dwelling would be on the left
then this is just showing you um kind of
the the design and layout of consider so
the the house itself um is adjacent the
highway then you've got garage and other
ancillary buildings for the residential
property behind that
so this is just kind of
going doing a kind of view of um site
from
the the driveway looking um to the to
the west so you've got the open fields
there and and the first bit in the
foreground is is the immunity space
next slide
so this is just looking at it from the
fence that separates the immunity space
to the paddock
um also looking to to the west there
then this is just looking to the
northwest so that shows the defense
between the paddock and the immunity
space and then you have got watertown in
the background
this is just panning round so
watertown's there rest of the immunity
space which this would be the new
dwellings part of their immunity space
so this is just coming around so kind of
where the dwelling would be would be
cited
this is also showing the sites so um
this will primarily be kind of turning
parking the garage which is
the building that will be adjacent the
highway and the dwelling is going to be
sat back within the site
that's just the site again
and this is just showing kind of where
the garage will be in relation to the
highway
and in the um background there you can
just see a glimpse of the neighboring
property which which is higher up
so this is just looking from the bottom
of the garden and kind of mainly towards
coppersada and then where the hedging is
that is that is where the dwelling will
be
and that's just looking kind of directly
um up onto the site um from part of the
immunity spaces proposed
so this is a picture taken on the site
looking to the existing access which
they will be utilizing for for both
properties
so these are just some photos and kind
of going down into watertown from from
the road um so the arrow is kind of
where the proposed wedding will be
to the right is caposado and then up on
the higher ground to the left is the
nearest neighboring property
so this is just kind of going up a lane
which connects into city well which you
then turn left onto the diddy well road
to the site um
so once again you can kind of see the
sporadic nature of the build form
and that's just another one so we go on
to the proposed block plan so as you can
see you might need to zoom in a little
bit sure thank you
and so you've got carpenter there where
the the main dwelling is kind of
directly on really well road and the
proposal is to put a detached garage um
at the front and then obviously the
dwelling is um going to sit behind that
so the dwelling will be
seen kind of further back from from the
existing dwelling that that's on site
so this is just the proposed elevations
for the site
and then if we go onto the floor plan so
it's a four bedroom detached dwelling as
um mentioned at the starting
presentation so um your usual kind of
layout with kitchen dining lounge
entrance at um ground floor and then all
the bedrooms at first floor
this is the plans for the proposed
garage so it will be six meters by six
meters and that's what will be at the
forefront with the access
so in the site visit it was kind of ask
for clarity on the the height of the the
dwelling um compared to the existing one
on site so
just to say from this proposed street
scene so from the the highway it would
look like the proposed wedding is a lot
lower than corsado on site however
cavazardo is right next to the highway
and the dwelling is approximately
between 11 and 13 meters into the site
so that that kind of shows a difference
so it is going to be further down in the
topography
so from the roadside um ridge height of
crosstalk is 9.2 um and the proposed
running is 7.2
but actually when you take kind of the
the actual ridge height further into the
site um the commissioner itself is
between 8.3 and 8.4 so there's kind of a
meter difference that from the highway
you wouldn't be able to see because it
is dug down into kind of the topography
because it is set back into the site
so just to go through them so the
material planning considerations
um as mentioned and seen in the report
um it is an undeveloped coast and it is
in the open countryside as a local
authority obviously we do have to
consider because of our five-year
housing land supply the tilted balance
that has all been detailed within the
principle of development and we've also
gone through kind of paragraph 80 of the
mppf um which obviously looks at
isolated homes with one or more
following circumstances which which
might allow it to be approved
as an officer i have gone through um all
of those kind of stipulations that we
could look at dwellings in the open
countryside um and concluded within the
principle
um to begin with that it was countries
restio seven and contrary to sto97
as i said we have to look at the tilted
balance so kind of went through the
other material considerations which are
discussed so
in terms of visual impact and landscape
character um
as i said it's in the undeveloped coast
this area does have a tranquil fill and
that's part of the the test for sto9 um
so kind of man-made disturbances um and
as i've put in the report that putting a
dwelling on this site will close that
gap of sporadic field form and all the
paraphernalia that comes comes with a
dwelling
in terms of impact on residential
immunity and
it is well distanced from coversado and
because there is no kind of other
neighbouring dwellings it will accord
with um the residential immunity
there is obviously kabusado has got
quite a large garden at the moment but
it is felt that the dwelling and the
immunity space that will be removed
actually will still leave it with
adequate immunity space for the intended
occupiers
in terms of highways deborah mountain
highways and were consulted and they
said that it should be dealt with
understanding advice after assessing the
plans there is adequate parking and
turning on sites um for the
new dwelling and then in terms of
ecology um a wildlife triple list of
woodport wasn't wasn't triggered for for
the site
in terms of others environmental
protection were consulted um
and they had asked for conditions on
construction works um and they'd asked
for an addition should any contamination
um be found that is if they were to be
approved so obviously they are they are
not on on the report
so taking into account the tilted
balance and and kind of the conclusion
it was on the basis in reference to
paragraph 11d
that it is considered that the adverse
impacts of this commission would
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
any benefits and therefore i recommend
refusal
thank you sarah
thank you chair uh just to make members
aware of a slight amendment on page 119
of your committee report on who's
improving to
currently
um the site lies with the designated
coast nest free zone
um that they should be the site lies
within suggested members to know that
there is a good reason
[Music]
that's the
presentation our first speaker
committing support to the application is
james mcelveen
[Music]
thank you chad
good morning to you all
i am jameson kelden i am the son of the
applicant sue and stu mcelveen
myself and my wife are a local couple
with a vision to build a forever home
both myself and my wife were born and
bred in the local area
my wife is from the lovely village of
heartland and i was raised in the
pictures village of ecuador
we're both very much in full support of
the local community
i have worked as a branch manager for a
building's merchant for the past five
years and my work as a police community
support officer for the past 14 years
serving the local communities of north
devon
this build would be our forever home to
raise a family and beans
be in the catchment area of local
education and facilities that we like to
support such as shops pubs and
restaurants or within walking distance
of the property
this would be a sustainable build that
is aesthetically pleasing to the local
area
with thought put in through my own
building knowledge put towards
the build energy efficiency where
possible such as solar panels and
electric car charging points
the plot is is is easily an adequate
size to accommodate both properties both
the existing property of cobasada and
this new build property
built on an affordable plot of land in
order to create a property that would
allow us to assist in the care of my
elderly parents as they grow older and
remain in their own home avoiding having
to move
into a care home this has highlighted
it's important to us all during the
recent pandemic
are struggling to find a property nearby
we looked at the new builds recently up
hit lane applegall we were informed by
the site agent that all of the first
bays have already been snapped up within
just one week
so many houses in this area are sadly
brought for holiday accommodation
we hope all our points are taken into
consider consideration and we look
forward to hearing from you thank you
thank you
my next speaker in support is sean
taylor
the agent
i want you to give you three minutes as
well to address the committees thank you
thank you chad and good afternoon
committee
the advocate son has clearly described
the housing needs we wish to support he
wishes to support his atari
retiring years of his family and to
enable him for them to remain in their
home not have to rely on the local
authority to provide care home provision
and for him to preserve the family unit
and social benefits
this application of approve could be
controlled by suitable conditions so
therefore the new dwelling could not be
considered an open market dwelling
therefore removing problems such young
families face today sourcing affordable
available
homes
what's that notwithstanding the comments
raised by the applicant i believe this
application be compliant with the
spatial strategy given the knowledge of
the lack of five-year housing supply
as confirmed in the case officer's
report
i quote
the council accepts that it cannot
currently demonstrate a five-year supply
of delivering housing
by virtue of this
being unable to demonstrate the
five-year supply of affordable housing
for the night seven of the national
planning policy framework
there is a need to
apply the presumption in favor of
suspense sustainable development
are set out in the
nppf
the presumption is a material
consideration in determining planning
applications for housing
there are no relevant development plan
policies local planning authorities
should grant planning permission
having said that lpas should only grant
planning permission for such an
application as you before you today
whilst being mindful of any adverse
impacts of doing so would significantly
and demonstrate demonstrably
outweigh the benefits
when assessed against policies of the
mppf
taken as a whole
i believe this application
would be compliant with policy st 21
subsection c
this policy states that the proposal for
the development outside the defined
settlement areas will be supported
where there is broadly consistence in
the social vision strategy
the police officer's objection seems to
be that because of scientists in the
open countryside it's contrary to policy
st-21 section c
however policy st 21 states that
development proposals outside settlement
limits should be supported
a site which is outside the defined
settlement limit must by its virtue in
the open countryside
so policy st 21 directly supports
development in the open countryside and
the case office's ground for actions can
that not fall therefore be sustained
the question then comes before
is the dwelling in this location broadly
consistent with the spatial vision
you could say that the use of the word
broadly in the policy gives a decision
maker both flexibility and discretion
but withstanding we could consider the
location site to be located only a short
distance from northern
which is in the main centre of the local
plan with provision of over 2 000
dwellings in the planned period
the allocations in the plan attributed
to northern includes the site's
development sites in appledore which is
actually located further from the order
than this application site and i should
wind up now
as previously mentioned in case officer
in a report the council accepts that
they're unable to demonstrate the
five-year supply of housing and that
didn't given all the caveats within the
mppf it follows that the planning
permission should be granted for the
proposed development unless any adverse
impacts doing so will significantly
demonstrate outweigh the benefits but
assess against the policy of this
framework for this reasons therefore the
principle of the proposed development is
successful and fully compliant with the
requirements of policy st 21 for the
adopted local plan in wide housing
positions and the direct need for the
applicant's family
i find the committee therefore to
preclude the proposals would be
compliant with the development policy
plan whilst delivering social benefits
for the applicant's family thank you
our next speaker is award member
uh councillor
afternoon councillors
hello hello
um it's very important to stress
councillors once again that you have an
application here for a dwelling in an
area of undeveloped coast
which is protected from development
under strategic policies st07 and sto9
in particular policy sto 97 sets the
position out very clearly that
development which detracts from the
unspoken character appearance and
tranquility in the area should not be
permitted
but i should emphasize that reference to
the area includes the proposed
development site as well as the
countryside surrounding it
your officer in section two of her
report concludes that the proposal would
introduce a new dwelling in this
location which will be contrary to the
existing build form and in the absence
of justifiable functional requirement
that the dwelling cannot be recently
located outside of the coast an estuary
zone it would detract from the unspoiled
character appearance and tranquility to
the areas to therefore conflict policies
sto 4 tm04 and sto97
the perusal of the site and the plans
for the application confirms the
findings of your officer that the tests
in st 097 would not be satisfied by the
proposed development at crescent the
victorian stroke edwardian house
i think is situated in open countryside
and is separate from other dwellings it
sits well on the site in its surrounding
garden and in the landscape but the
proposed house would be situated fairly
close to it would be built in a
different and contemporary style and
with different materials
and would therefore strongly detract
visually from the crescent scene it
would occupy much of the garden space
and would encroach on the immunity of
cobasada and the occupants would
generate more vehicular traffic on a
narrow lane which enters a blind
junction just yards from the side
the new dwelling built in a different
style from the present one would also
adversely impact on the white or
undeveloped coast as well as the aonb
and ssi an impact exacerbated by the
dwellings relatively close proximity to
the present house
i gather that the applicants have stated
that the post house is necessary so that
her son and wife can look after her and
her husband in her old age
which i certainly sympathise with
however the planning officer has
referred to the remnant public policies
regarding this submission
including para 80 of the national
planning framework relating to rural
workers
and she's shown that their provisions do
not apply to this application
regarding policy s2097 she's indicated
that the proposed development does not
satisfy satisfy the policy's fourth test
that is that the house could not be
built outside the undeveloped coast
your officers also refer to policy
sto-74 regarding development to the open
countryside and show that the
application does not fit with the
requirements to prove economic and
social need in that policy
and the applicant has not shown that
there are exceptional reasons to
outweigh the requirements of the
relevant policies
suggest that if the reasons given by the
applicant for building a house are
accepted by you then this would set a
precedent encouraging more applicants of
similar or other special family
circumstances to apply for houses in the
undeveloped coast and open countryside
in addition of course the suggested
purpose and justification for dwelling
can only be a temporary situation
as unfortunately it is inevitable that
the occupants of cobasada
will not always be there
the result would be a dwelling which
would not serve its original purpose and
would not meet with any of the policies
as set out in the offices report
as to conditioning permission for the
new dwelling for social use as suggested
by councillor ford in his calling of the
application he has not explained the
practicalities of how the council would
tie the use of the houses together in
perpetuity
what uses the properties will be defined
as and what legal basis there will be
for such an arrangement
furthermore the applicant has made no
such request for such an arrangement and
even if it were considered possible by
the council it could effectively be a
refusal of commission of the current
proposal for a separate dwelling house
it would be a reducing commission i
should say
such an arrangement would no doubt be
the subject in the later date of an
application to lift the planning
condition
councillors to grant permission for this
application would be to dismiss the
strategic policies which were designed
to protect what is left of the green
spaces around northern africa
these areas are precious to local people
and the desire to protect them has been
reflected in the local plan and also in
the drafting of the northern
neighborhood
many people don't have the luxury of
living in the miles of many local people
don't have the luxury of living in the
miles of open countryside enjoyed by
those who reside in the rural parts of
torridge
our remaining green spaces are meant to
be protected from development and so i
ask you please to fully apply the
relevant policies to this application
and vote for refusal
thank you
thank you councillor
that's the end of the speakers i did
have a call and you'll see
[Music]
for different reasons
and i think i had a phone call just good
morning from council ford who hoped he
might get here but it's really important
it would give the application
uh thorough consideration i said well
we're always doing all the applications
particularly from the social benefit
point of view you'll see from his
calling that he mentioned
about this report counseling
um
i have to say
on this time i fully agree with cancer
so i'm like-minded now to
that we are going to propose that we
accept
this application
and essentially that benefit for the
family
is paramount to local people
now
had lots of things where locals can't
afford it around but it's been moved out
the area so only the st 21 i believe it
is a sustainable development
it doesn't impact the immunities of
government either because it's in their
garden it's their parents it's in their
garden okay now to me
the traffic movements up that lane well
any lane there can be used for cut for
his own cut for over traffic anyway so i
i don't agree with that i'll give the
council haynes that additional traffic
movements in there you've got a lot of
locals and visitors that like at the
moment running through there's lovely
areas to live to me um if you want to
put condition on it can you put
conditions on it let's get somebody's
entirety one that two houses together
is there any such need to do so i don't
believe with such need to condition it
to be honest it's for local people you
understand look family moving in
i have no affiliation with the family i
don't know the family so i have no ties
there no interest at all i believe that
we should be not refusing we should be
accepting this application to be granted
an application
council
disagree with that because
um this is an open market house
there's no local needs being specified
this seems to be a room run the one we
had recently at heartland yeah at the
very last moment they claimed local
needs um if they want to put a housing
for local needs i've got no problem with
that but as it stands at the moment this
doesn't agree with any of our policies
and the problem is as council have
pointed out
that once
the current owners pass on
we've got two houses and i don't follow
councilman with gobson logic that
this is you know for locals they're
going to have two houses you've got to
buy at once
but could we not get this changed into a
local needs property
i mean that
i mean the people have talked about it
for a local for a local family so why
can't we change it into a local need
we've we've done this before
the plans committee
yes just to come back obviously they
have had pre-applications and all the
way along it's been open markets they've
never come forward with it trying to be
local needs obviously for local needs it
would be policy dm 24 which we're all
settlements this isn't obviously a rural
settlement this is open countryside um
but as with the committee last time um
with that application obviously the the
applicants can come back with it but
obviously today we are determining it as
a as a open market dwelling okay
but they could come back with it for a
local needs there's nothing stopping
them obviously we can't say today
whether that would be acceptable but
there's nothing stopping them from
resubmitting and the policy would be dm
24 though which is rural settlement and
this is over the countryside
yeah i mean i was going to bring that up
about the open countryside because in
your report you also say that the
property will be unless dated but i
don't consider that it would be a
resonator because on several of your
slides you can see other houses in the
area so i don't accept the term that it
will be appreciated
um
and then you talk about the tilted
balance
so i
agree with councilman goff
um
it has been
recommended for refusal but i'm going
the other way on the tilted balance i
think it falls with policies dno1 impact
on residential immediacy it complies
with dm05 and dm06 highways and sd-14
so i would recommend that the
application is approved and i know it's
an open market house but we can't change
that but i'm still going to recommend
approval on those grills
and balance
okay
[Music]
thank you chair
um
yeah just to reiterate really what
service uh she's just giving uh members
um i would also
state that we
as we awares that memphis video are
where that every application is deadly
on its own merits
however to previous application this
location um could
raise further applications of similar
dwellings in the open countryside
and also to highlight the location in
the undeveloped coast um and we have
strong policy considerations in relation
to that um and as the officer has laid
out with a report
no matter if his level needs or not um
it is country close policies and it will
be um adding additional built form in
the undeveloped coasts uh which is
something that we're the local plan um
your local plan is very strong so that
needs to be brought into that balance as
well
um if members weren't minded to approve
the application by a vote
members may wish to have a discussion
with the
officer in the first instance to discuss
conditions because we wanted to be
conditioned with standard conditions
time conditions etc
so you may want to discuss those before
developers as well
[Music]
can't be sure
can i just ask then if so much
importance is being put on aonb and
coastal well the aomb
so this one so this is undeveloped coast
so it's not in the aomp itself so they
wouldn't
necessarily be be consulted on that it's
obviously us as officers using the st09
um
and as sean um as quite rightly pointed
out it is sto 97 that we do have to
consider um and that's the one that we
spoke with our policy team team on um
but no amd weren't weren't consulted on
the application
one more point then if i'm still going
to recommend approval um subject to
condition during agent to construction
management plan and the contamination
land condition
well
reading this one through
going for the balance for the tilted
balance argument because we've not got
that five years
housing land supply
i was reading through on page 115 about
tilted balance
this is one of those difficult ones that
we have again
where
you want to help house local families we
all want to help house local families
where it comes up against certain
policies
and then you so that this is the
decision we've always got the difficulty
of making
do we
think that the tilted balance is in
favor of this development because
there's no huge detrimental impact
on the area because this is already in
within the court of egypt
i hear what council hayes says about the
victorian if it is victorian
of
course and now
i don't think that another modern
dwelling comes back and having a
detraction on that building
a lot of victorian stuff not through
with anyway but
it is within the curtain that if this
was a for me if this was a field
or a small plot of land off the lane i
would have a different view about it
but because it is within
the cartilage of an existing dwelling
and let's think
years ago
houses were built already you bought a
piece of land you put a house
we have policies and we've got to deal
with the policies
unless there's
any uh benefits in not doing and i think
with this
i tend to agree with councillor
that a counselor would often counsel
craig
because it was an awkward balance it is
a difficult spirit
there's no way we condition this to
attach it to publicized under the
current application
i don't think such a condition would
meet your testing conditions um so if a
patient wants to come into that
condition i don't know how to defend
that um
[Music]
um you mentioned the construction
management plan and contamination
condition
i'd also advise you on the condition of
linking into the plans
as submitted absolutely his own
permission and also the time commission
standard time permission um
yeah i'll go with that yeah
absolutely
until
as as peter christie already proposed
that to refuse no it's been proposed to
grant this by counseling the gulf state
background
right
[Music]
it is a difficult
that no landscaping scheme was submitted
in the application so again members were
reminded to approve
um
we would recommend subject to condition
requiring elastic extreme pressure
[Music]
[Music]
because
[Music]
and we need to be consistent on this
council we have one just recently in the
heartland where
you know it wasn't it was an open market
housing yet they came along and claimed
the local needs we've told them to go
back and apply for local needs as our
officers said they can do that here we
seem to be completely altering our
position and say oh well yeah he told us
he doesn't work um i'm sorry but we do
need to be consistent well for me that
heartbreak was slightly different from
this that was a separate sound it wasn't
in the cartilage
of an existing large victorian dwelling
so for me
there is a difference and we have to
look at each application on its merits
which is what i've done
it's been moved by councillor mcgoff to
grant this application
with the conditions that some people
have to agree with
sarah and children
that sort of been mentioned
and secondly by councillor craigie
can we just check that's a great
investment but
[Music]
councillor craigie or councillor leather
poor councillor lot
councillor mcgrath or councillor watson
councillor wiseman four
that's seven four chair and two against
that's ground two
application today
application 17
from pages 12132
so yes i said this is a conversion of a
redundant agricultural building into a
one-bedroom dwelling at the farm lower
clean
so this is just to show the location
plan so the site is um outlined in red
and the correct certificates have been
um submitted so um it's not all within
the applicant's ownership so they have
um submitted certificate b so the right
procedure has been taken with that um
and then to the kind of north east
the south east you've got the the
applicant's um dwelling that she she
owns
we go to the next slide
so this is just showing you a satellite
image of of the location
so this is just showing you the the
existing block plan um this has been
subject to a site visit as well so
obviously when the photos come up it'll
be more apparent the the structure that
is there um but this is just showing
where where the building is located next
this is just showing the existing
elevations
um of what kind of structure and
building is there and so you've got the
the garage there kind of on the south
west um and you can see part of that on
the west elevation
and then the front elevation there's the
east on the left-hand side um and then
the north and south
so this is just to show you um the the
photos so this is actually accessed off
of a private road so where this picture
is being taken from is the the highway
um that goes on to the private road
which goes towards the building
so if we go to the next slide
so this is just kind of walking further
up um so now kind of on the private road
and you can just see there next to um
kind of vegetation there that is that is
the building um and then on the right
hand side is is a building that um the
applicant owns
so this is the building itself um so
you can see that is the the southern
elevation
so this is what they're they're
indicating as kind of the the driveway
um and you can see part of the southern
elevation there
so this is a section of the the east
elevation
um so this is the the kind of corner of
the south and the east elevation there
and then the next slide kind of shows
the east elevation in like nearly its
entirety
and then
that's kind of a better one to show you
that's the full full east elevation um
against the private road there
so this is just to show you kind of and
to give you a perspective of the east
elevation in relation to the
neighbouring properties um towards the
east there that is the private road and
public right way going between the
between the two
so this is one of the windows on the
north elevation
and then the next slide
just showing you the path that goes past
and then yeah if you go on to the next
slide sean that just shows you um better
aspect of of that north elevation with
the window um and the area um
that has been detailed as kind of a bike
shed and then obviously you've got the
private road next to it
so this is just showing you the
neighboring property to the north
as i said once again in between it is is
the private road separating the two
next slides
so this is the the west elevation so
that is the garage um and you can see
the the properties behind which are the
neighboring properties to the east
this is just another um kind of view of
of the garage um which is to be part of
of the conversion
so this is the the west elevation so you
can see the garage part of the the other
side of the west elevation and then
you've got um one of the neighboring
properties there to the south
and that's just showing it again in
relation to to the properties
with the garage and this is taken from
from that west elevation
so this is just showing you where the
the garage and um
part of the immunity is going to be so
this is kind of between the museum and
the driveway
and then the next side you've got the
kind of west and south elevation of the
building
the next slide is the the driveway um
with the neighbouring properties to the
east there
and then these are just a few um kind of
photos from the garage um and the
immediate space looking out so that is
um a neighboring garage and if we
go on to the next slide
you can see their immunity goes um kind
of further to the west there and then if
we go to the next slide their property
is the one further back um so the garage
is kind of at the forefront on the right
there and their property is um in the
background and
to the left of the garage
so this is just looking from the garage
itself um to the neighboring property to
the south
[Music]
and then that's another one looking kind
of towards that that south property
so these are just some that are from
inside the building um so this is
looking towards the north
next slide
and this is kind of looking at the the
east elevation
and then this is looking out east
towards the the neighboring properties
which these openings are going to be
utilized within the proposal
um
that's the window to the north
and then that is looking to to the south
and then this is just looking to the
east so this is looking um kind of more
to the
um
south east
and then that's looking more to kind of
the north east
different angle
so this is just showing you this is from
from the coast path so you've got the
the kind of
buildings there this is going to be in
the background there has been changes to
the pitch of the roof and that was um
put forward by the conservation officer
to mimic the pictures of roof that's
already on the site
so this is just showing you some
pictures from 2009 because a lot has
been mentioned within comments of the
structure and a lot of deterioration so
these photos were taken in 2009 um just
to demonstrate that actually a lot of it
is still there and actually it hasn't
deteriorated much since since that time
so these can just
um can quickly
be gone through so the main difference
is some of the vegetation's gone but all
in terms of the inside and outside it
hasn't deteriorated much so just going
through the plans this is the proposed
um
block plan so you've got the main kind
of building in the garage that's going
to be converted
the immunity is to kind of the south
west there and then obviously the
driveway is is to the south
so these are the proposed elevations as
i said there were changes to materials
and the picture of the booth during the
course of the application and this was
due to discussions with the conservation
officer
um so the the bottom half is kind of the
stonework that's already there
the top half was originally cladding and
we asked for it to be kind of a white
render so that it fitted in with the
aesthetics of of the surrounding
neighbouring properties and slight
windows have been amended and some of
the roof lights have been reduced and
just to limit that that impact
and this was all led by
the conservation officer
so the proposed ground floor plan so it
has also changed to kind of a one
bedroom um with kind of a study office
and then next first floor plan so it's
kind of the upside down living so the
bedrooms are on the ground floor and
then the first floor is your kind of
kitchen sitting and dining rooms
this is just showing the vehicle access
and swept path um analysis that has been
submitted to show that there is kind of
adequate turning um for for a vehicle
let me just so just to go through the
material planning considerations
the principle of development is in sto6
so it is within the development boundary
this is a conversion which is more
preferable to your officers and rather
than knocking it down and rebuilding
something on-site um the drawings have
kind of going on to the impact and
character appearance have tried to
utilize the existing openings and kind
of keep as much as a kind of historic
nature of the building as possible um
and then have um done amendments to to
obviously try and fit it aesthetically
into the neighbouring properties
we've looked at impact on immunity there
was objection comments on impact
on immunity it has been detailed in the
report how we have considered these
um and how it is felt that there
isn't significant impact in terms of
harm to amenities of neighbouring
occupiers or the intended occupiers
themselves
highway safety is considered that it
accords with our policies same with
drainage it's going into the mains um
drainage
the main sewer system and then ecology
there has been an ecology statement
which has been submitted and we've
reviewed and consider it in accordance
with our policies
once again environmental protection in
terms of other have put forward
conditions which which have been put
on the the approval
so in conclusion um
as officer we're recommending approval
to grant the permission
thank you sarah thank you for that
presentation
and we've got um four contributors to
this
first one to speak against the
application is
testing hunter
good morning i'm talking today on behalf
of my father who has lived on the lane
for over 30 years our submitted
objections remain as previously stated
we've sought professional advice
throughout
this advice remains that this
application is contrary to the local
plan
in particular policies dmr 1 4 5 6 and
dm-27 against which an appeal would be
determined the planning history and
material consideration goes back over 35
years and the comments rejections are
remarkably consistent constrained site
overlooking immunity space parking
turning highway dangers and being more
than conversion
the 2000 application did not allow any
windows on the first floor and did not
use the site so fully all in the all
immediate neighbours have objected for
varying reasons plus very clear strong
objections from northern town council
and the ramblers association
i wish to identify the following four
issues
one
all other applications have been for two
to three bedrooms despite some being
smaller builds never never has it been
submitted as a one-bedroom unit until
now when bedroom two has been renamed as
a study
there are no physical changes and it can
revert back
two the lane
the report requires a nine to seven pm
work schedule and for the single track
lane to remain open for the public it
does not stipulate driving access for my
father or neighbor
even if it did we just can't see how it
will be possible what about risks to
pedestrians
iowa highways recommended refusal in
2000 with detailed reasons they declined
to comment on a private lane now hence
the standing instructions understand but
the lane is more restricted than in 2000
and is far busier with pedestrians due
to the development above the lane
this application does not protect or
enhance the lane
the sweatpath analysis referred to is
for a small car river but it is
reversing into a restricted lane the
report suggests overspill parking to the
east i think that is on the well-used
public road at the bottom is thus this
is a suitable solution
number three this the site is so tight
that the barn walls stand on the lane
border and another neighbor's land so
even a roof overhang will trespass the
airspace above the lane owned by my
father
we are concerned about that and if the
delay needs to be dug up for any work
the report says a small area of
rebuilding on wall tops is needed
our professional advisors state the
application significantly understand
understates the extent of the work
needed as evidence in pictures like
visits and i note the pictures but there
are other comments
previous applications stated for
previous applications going back a long
time that states the walls would have to
be demolished to the festival level how
is it not necessary 35 years later the
true extent of the work is just not
known
we believe this is far more than a
conversion and so cannot rely on course
dm 27.
to summarize the planning report
conclusion states that this application
will not result in a harmful impact on
neighbours the professional device sort
the recent objections from all
neighbours ramblers association and
northern town council and a polluting
wood-burning stone strongly state
otherwise
the rebuilding of this barn comes with a
high detrimental cost to neighbours and
the lane
our overwhelming concern relates to the
land
we believe this application should be
rejected being in conflict with several
policies of the local plan with no
material planning considerations to
outweigh the policies
thank you
our next speaker against this
application is jerry scott
and you've got three minutes for you
thank you jeff address good afternoon
having lived at noaa clean for 22 years
i am aware of the detrimental effect
this proposal will have on the residents
living nearby
berryman's and cleve cottage are in my
ownership
both
grade 2 listed buildings
as merely a custodian i consider to have
a duty of care and responsibility during
my lifetime
not only to maintain the properties but
to protect the historic area for future
generations to enjoy
my objection is not necessarily to the
renovation per se
but it is based on the proposal itself
the amended plans do nothing to resolve
the direct overlooking whilst the change
of description lacks transparency and
openness
and is somewhat disappointing
there are no less than seven objections
five of which are all nearby residents
in addition northern parish council
recommend refusal
ramblers object
i note the absence of any support for
this proposal
the building has been in a state of
serious dilapidation for many years
so what is proposed is not a conversion
but a rebuild
the proposed development involves
increasing the height of the structure
beyond its existing height making it
effectively a new two-story house
due to the building's location opposite
and at right angles to cleave cottage in
berryman's there will be severe direct
overlooking into
and domination of our cottages
the access lane is very limited in width
and extra traffic will conflict with
existing users of the public footpath
i would also emphasize the dilapidated
state of the building and the scale of
what is being proposed
in such a handy location
the checkered plans history over many
decades are well documented
these plans are fraught with problems
and safety risks risks which seriously
affecting the enjoyment and privacy of
the residents
in october 2000 permission was
eventually
granted
with conditions
the born to be ancillary to cleve farm
with overflow accommodation only
with no first floor windows facing clear
cottage
this seemed to center
approach and was supported by myself
but nothing was ever done
and lapsed
having lived at cleve cottage for five
years i fear for the current occupiers
as i know what a devastating effect this
will have on their enjoyment
the kitchen diner and main bedroom will
be closely and directly and
significantly overlooked and affected
forever
the overbearing amassing is far
from in keeping and is not appropriate
in this tight location
as well as the bomb being situated much
higher than cleve cottage
impact on immunity in the committee
report states minimal
minimal impact on surrounding properties
along with other dismissive comments
of course
this is clearly not the case
will be overlooked from the new window
in the north wall into the dining room
office space along with the front and
rear gardens and driveway
this application will have little or no
impact on the contribution to the local
community
and housing needs
finally we were told that the long burn
was to be deleted
and also let's
consider
protecting our backs with at least a
survey
thank you thank you
my next speaker in support of the
application is lynn bennett
i want you've settled you've got three
minutes to address the committees okay
[Music]
i bought creed farm barn and damage in
august 96 keith farm didn't wholly own
the gravel strip when october 2000
planners granted two-bed holiday
accommodation in the barn
in april 2012 i bought the land
significantly increasing available
immunity space it carries easement on
the private road for right-of-way and
vehicular access at all times for all
purposes allowing the 2021 application
for full residential use if granted to
separate barn and land from true farm
long-standing land ownership boundary
issues delayed development now legally
resolved a land truck land registry
tribunal ruling in favor of clean farm
and cottage
my daughter a new qualified doctor
serving in the royal navy wishes to get
on the property ladder we've lived here
26 years and love it
creating an affordable first home with
character she can fund where she grew up
led to this application
it would provide an important home base
for her when on deployment permanent
dwelling when her commission ends and
then she hopes to work locally as a gp
conversion for a local person aspect of
the community fit for purpose and with a
sustainable future
there's very good access onto the public
highway over clean the barn accessible
from the widest shortest past the lane
entrance with clear visibility from
lower cleave
2021 development at
cleveland's park saw all large lorries
delivering for infrastructure using this
junction outside clea farm to park off
load heavy machinery and building
materials transferred in small dunker
trucks for their onward journey
demonstrating suitable access for any of
our construction deliveries and little
detriment to neighbor access
the two properties further up the lanes
only vehicle access is via the lane
barn boundaries are such that i could
erect bollards or fence off to their
full extent but i have not done so to
maintain their vehicular access used
over 50 years for cursive and behavior
the haven extended in 23rd 2006 adding a
second story with increased footprint
despite potential increase in occupants
and traffic all materials machinery
etcetera paints and lower cleave up the
entire length of the lane absolutely
but
further down it can be done
unrestricted parking is plentiful any
time or locally but now immediately
above them in goodwood park and down at
lane if the lane is temporarily closed
i recognize rambler's concern about
footpath safe access the three-step
areas on the barn boundary to the lane
will be retained
providing safe places to shelter from
vehicles driving on past the barn to
cursor and the haven slowing their
speeds benefiting pedestrians
minimum lane closures will be agreed
with authorities and interested parties
i recognise labour's concerns about
construction i'm one too
and will diligently work adhere into all
council working hours
i discuss my plans openly and on many
occasions at length with mr and mrs
scott resulting in significant
compromise on my part to accommodate
their recommendations we also joined
together over many years for the land
registry tribunal
barn has deteriorated over their teams
you're getting quality
deteriorated over decades deserving the
sensitive recommendation which this
application achieves while significantly
enhancing the listed cluster and
locality i thank you very much for the
consideration thank you
our final contribution is from deborah
somerville
engagement
[Music]
good afternoon my name is deborah
somerville chartered architect and agent
for this application the proposal which
is recommended for approval is located
within the development boundary and has
existing pedestrian and vehicular access
rights over the lane our proposal does
not alter the footprint of the built
form or the entrance to the site
the application has been called in on a
number of points which i will address in
more detail
historically the site has always had
vehicle accidents since it was a farm
and our client has used it for
occasional parking since taking
ownership over 25 years ago it had the
garage and sufficient parking spaces for
up to three cars there are no
restrictions legal or otherwise to
prevent our client from using the site
for this purpose
we consulted with denver county highways
prior to the application being submitted
utilizing a vehicular tracking program
this demonstrated that small car can
access site and maneuver safely dcc
highways concluded that access was
satisfactory as was the junction between
the lane and the public highway at noaa
please
no concerns were raised by the public
right-to-way officer it should also be
noted that there is unrestricted parking
at lower cleve just a couple of minutes
walk away
the total area provided for immunity
space is 64 square meters this is
considered more than adequate especially
when compared with that approved for
some new build properties on larger
housing states in the area
the development on completion will not
affect the public right away
during construction pedestrian access
will be maintained any restriction to
vehicular access would only be as a
result of the need to connect to public
services as would be the case on any
development
the suitability for conversion has been
confirmed by a qualified structural
engineer
stonework will be repaired and the
lightweight timber frame constructed on
site to form first floor walls and roof
structure
underpinning will be carried out if
required inside the footprint of the
built form
21 years ago planning approval was
granted to convert the building into
holiday nets however the design did not
comply with building regulations
approved document part b which covers
fire safety and therefore could never be
constructed in accordance with approved
drawings
planning policy has changed
significantly since then and redundant
outbuildings can now be converted into
dwellings especially when they are
located within the development boundary
the location dictates that people can
and will look in the windows of the
properties that line the lane should
they wish to do so
bedrooms are traditionally located on
the first floor so we flip this to
further protect the privacy of our
neighbours
during the application process we have
worked with the planning department and
the conservation officer to look at
concerns raised and have tweaked the
proposals to include their
recommendations to reduce the height of
the eaves increase the ridge height
and substituting the sea declining to um
to render and also some alteration to
the fenestration as requested by mr mrs
scott
due to the size of the second bedroom it
was also recommended to us that we
should show this as a home office
because realistically it's the bench you
can only just live one way
the conservation officer has confirmed
that the site should not be considered
as forming part of the curvature of
energy building due to the fact that the
land is dissected by the lane
converting this building into a modest
dwelling will provide a sustainable
reuse which will safeguard its future as
stated in sarah chapel's report its
restoration will improve the overall
appearance of the area and should
therefore be supported thank you
thank you
[Music]
that concludes the public contributions
to this application
and
i call this one into the
reasons that are there so i can't stop
this
borrowing on this for me this
this has always been an eye before
um
it's been like that because it's been
said for many many years
and this sarah showed us the first class
from 2009
not really deteriorated a lot since then
um
and you can see from those photographs
um
it used to be a two-story building
i was concerned about the turning that
is obviously there's no turning on cyber
vehicles
um and i've driven up to that corner and
just rounded it with my car which is
quite a large car
but i would like to try and reverse mine
into that parking space but a small
cargo coin has been shown by the
tracking
and
i would like
i don't know if we know what the rich i
did this is compared to
clear farms lead package
um not
compared to clear farm and clean cottage
but i have got the
rich height of um
the proposal because of the topography
obviously the ridge height just does
change throughout um but on the east
elevation kind of at the the largest um
section the ridge height is 7.5 meters
[Music]
uh yes on the proposed east elevation so
just where the the gates are so if you
take it from there that is 7.5 because
obviously it does slow
upwards so i've done kind of the maximum
bridge height on that elevation and
that's the elevation you do see
um from the coast path
and i've seen the comment from northern
town council mentioned this as well but
this isn't this theory
no so as explained um our conservation
officer was consulted on the application
um and what they have considered is
because of the um
that it's been severed because of the
kind of ongoing private road that's
there um so they believe that it has
been severed and therefore it isn't a
um under the curtain listing okay
and in the report it mentions
obscure closing as one of the conditions
that i i've got i printed off
and it mentions i think it mentions the
so that is on the west elevation
yeah so as um
mentioned the agent um explained explain
obviously the the kind of living
accommodation got moved upstairs so that
obviously that is the primary area that
most people utilize so to limit the
impact on neighbouring i mean you see
they flipped it upside down to have
bedrooms downstairs and living upstairs
because the living is upstairs when you
look from the west that is some of the
immunity don't know sure um one of the
pictures sean was the garage if we go
back the other way
i told you
yes the east elevation is mainly going
to be the
bedrooms and the first floor have no
windows for the east elevations
so there's roof lights and which
wouldn't be able to be kind of looked
out of um on this elevation because that
is immunity space that is why the agents
have put forward obscure glazing because
one of them is by the kitchen sink so
you
would be looking out of that one um
quite a lot and one of the other ones
it well it's one of them they've done it
to protect so the window itself where
i'm stood right by the garage so
actually one of the windows is further
down that west elevation because of the
levels you would be able to see
out that way and that's why they have
obscure glaze that that wasn't
recommendations of ours that is
something that came in um when the first
drawings came in um was that they wish
to because the west elevation window one
of them is just slightly back so you
would see around that garage into that
immunity space and that's why these um
put forward to obscure plays it
yeah
for me more importantly is obscure
glazing on the east elevation in the
bedroom windows and in those uh bellics
in the roof as well
because that they're the closest to
cleve
farm and clean cottage
yeah i know it was said people can walk
up the public right away and look in the
windows at cleve farm
but we're talking about people looking
from this proposed development i think
they ought to be obscuring the guys i'm
not worried about on the west elevation
[Music]
i'll leave it at that today
yeah i've just got one small concern i
picked up just now the last speaker she
described the second bedroom in the
description it says a one bedroom
dwelling so yeah
[Music]
well it is
originally they were it was shown as two
bedrooms but now they've changed into a
study stroke home office
but the last speaker quoted the second
bedroom so that was
so we looked um just to come back on
that chair so we
looked at it obviously the the
two-bedroom second bedroom was very
tight there's only a certain way you
could physically get a bed in there um
we looked at it in terms of parking in
the meeting space um and
kind of um speaking with kind of
planning managers and team leaders it
was considered that as a one-bedroom
dwelling the immunity space would be
more adequate than it would be if it was
a two-bedroom dwelling so that's why it
was converted to one however
out of planning out for planning well
anybody can change internally their
house so but we are considering it as a
one-bedroom wedding
counselor
can we just go back to the elevations
can you show me the east elevation
which one is it
so the top left so this one
so you say they can look out there
no they can't that's why i said they
can't look out those bellex windows so
they are just roof lights they wouldn't
physically be able to look out of them
because
so yeah the bedroom window so on that
east elevation um the roof lights they
can't look out of yes the bedroom ones
they can but they are utilizing existing
openings so they're not proposing any
further openings they're only um
utilizing the existing openings um from
an officer point of view when we were to
um kind of putting forward a
recommendation it wasn't felt the
obscure glazing was needed um but
obviously that's something for for the
council well i would i would have
thought there should be obstacles in
person
i'm not worried about the obscure place
in the opposite elevation the west one
because
and the southern elevation which is
where the parking area is proposed to be
the large window there is honest i think
on the staircase yes this is so correct
there's no issue with that one
as i said at the start this
derelict property has been an eyesore
there in a mess for a long time
i do take the point that any development
of it any building what going on
will have a bit of effect on the
language on the private taxes for
example
of the vision for all of you left so if
you have a one bedroom apology that
you're gonna
have more traffic you know because you
might could probably go out every day
whereas if it's a permanent residence
you wouldn't get too much traffic well
the owner did say this was supposed to
be
an affordable dwelling for the daughters
in development
there's a firsthand home
i mean
that's not that's me
i mean
i'm impressed that you know the accurate
time taking notice and taken on board
comments that our conservation officer
has said and has you know changed some
of the aspects so i will recommend
approve the west berlin office's
recommendation second that
can i i'd like to have this obscure
glaze in the windows three windows at
the ground floor level
they're the bedrooms aren't they yeah
but you could look straight from those
straight into the other curtains
straight in
across that's it's only a narrow little
lane that you look straight into the
windows it clearly found two cottage
from there
no reason why they shouldn't look too
close can i just say once a whole yeah
sorry
would you be happy with that additional
well i don't but i don't consider it
necessarily obviously the conservation
officer or the planning officer don't
consider it necessary
everybody
right so
it's been moved by councillor lock
to approve
and secondly by council of watson
[Music]
and one abstention
[Music]
all right we'll move on then yeah eight
on the agenda is imperial decisions
summary there are none
nine is possible for no cost
[Music]
between thirty first of the third and
twenty
11
are the planning decisions
on pages 134
243
a list of delegated planning decisions
concert constantly abbreviations and
application types and films
between the 31st of march and the 28th
of april
i'm loads of mentioned one there will be
anybody
[Music]
yeah yeah so this one here was in
relation to the creation of pacific that
says um they would have been created on
uh private land on that cultural land um
there is a um a tourism site adjacent
there
but it's also within the aoe
and there's concerns to me of your
partnership and your officers in
relation to the impact on the aomb from
the passing base but there's no
justification put forward either for the
need for them um so it's potential to
unlock future development in the aomd
okay
right okay item
12
was irrelevant item 13 there's no closed
session so i declare the meeting
close